ROLL FOR US.
BATES HERE MONNING HERE MONNING
HERE ROB.
WILL PRESENT WILK HEREATKINS
HERE HAPPENS HERE.
THANK YOU.
I I UNDERSTAND THAT MISTER ROTH
IS ON HIS WAY --
LET ME ASK OUR MY COLLEAGUES WHO
ARE HERE IF THERE IS INTEREST IN
GOING AHEAD AND DOING A CONSENT
CALENDAR.
I WOULD ENTERTAIN A MOTION FOR
ANY OF THE ITEMS TWO THROUGH
EIGHT BUT I'LL LET YOU.
LET ME KNOW IF THAT'S
APPROPRIATE.
OKAY THANK YOU THAT WOULD BE
BILL REFERRALS ITEM TO STANDING
COMMITTEES ITEM THREE FOUR AND
FIVE SELECT COMMITTEES ITEMS.
SIX I WAS SUB COMMITTEES ITEM
SEVEN AND FLOORED KNOWLEDGE MINT
ITEM.
EIGHT IT'S SIDE EXECUTIVE.
OKAY.
THANK YOU THREE SENATOR.
I APPRECIATE THE EFFICIENCY --
MAN SECRETARY WANT TO CALL THE
ROLL.
SENATORS BATES.
BATES AYE MONNING.
MONNING AYE ROTH.
WILK HI WILK AYE ATKINS AYE.
AND LET'S KEEP THE ROLE OPEN SO
THAT WHEN OUR COLLEAGUE IS HERE
HE CAN VOTE ON THE CONSENT.
CALENDAR [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
AND WITH THAT WE WILL --
GO RIGHT TO ITEM NUMBER ONE
EIGHTY GOVERNOR'S APPOINTEES AND
SECRETARY OF ENVIRONMENTAL
PROTECTION AGENCY AND LET ME
INVITE.
MR JARED BLOOMIN FILLED UP
[inaudible] TO THE MICROPHONE
AND DESK WELCOME.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
YEAH I KNOW IT TAKES A LITTLE
ADJUSTMENT --
HIS HISTORIC CHAIRS --
WE WOULD INVITE YOU TO
ACKNOWLEDGE ANYONE THAT MIGHT BE
HERE -- WITH
YOU AND TO GO RIGHT INTO YOUR
COMMENTS AND THEN WE WILL TURN
IT OVER TO THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS
WELCOME.
THANK YOU.
I'M GOOD AFTERNOON CHECK INS AND
TO BE WITH YOU TODAY AND ON THAT --
BEEN APPOINTED BY GOVERNOR
NEWSOME AS SECRETARY OF
CALIFORNIA'S ENVIRONMENTAL
PROTECTION AGENCY.
I AM SEEKING YOUR CONFIRMATION
SO THAT MY HAVE THE PRIVILEGE OF
EQUITABLY IMPLEMENTING CALLIE
PA'S MISSION. TO ENSURE PUBLIC
HEALTH ENVIRONMENTAL QUALITY AND
ECONOMIC VITALITY.
THROUGH THE EFFECTIVE USE OF
SCIENCE AND THE LAW AND BY
ENGAGING COMMUNITIES
TRANSPARENTLY.
WE HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
IMPROVE THE LIVES OF MILLIONS OF
CALIFORNIA.
WE FACE MANY CHALLENGES FROM THE
WEST AIR QUALITY IN THE NATION.
THE MORE THAN ONE MILLION PEOPLE
LACKING ACCESS TO SAFE AND
AFFORDABLE DRINKING WATER. TO
THE LEGACY OF TOXIC
CONTAMINATION IN NEARLY EVERY
COMMUNITY TO THE INCREASINGLY
DEVASTATING IMPACTS OF CLIMATE
CHANGE.
ISSUES THAT OLD REQUIRE.
URGENT ACTION.
THESE CHALLENGES THESE
CHALLENGES ARE NOT INTRACTABLE.
IF WE LISTEN TO THE VOICES OF
COMMUNITY MEMBERS ADOPT THE
INNOVATIVE SPIRIT OF BUSINESSES.
AND WHAT COLLABORATIVELY ACROSS
GOVERNMENT AGENCIES WE CAN AND
WILL MAKE MEASURABLE PROGRESS.
IMPROVING CALIFORNIA'S
ENVIRONMENT PRESENTS HUGE
WORKFORCE AND ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT OPPORTUNITIES FROM
SOLAR ENERGY TO ELECTRIC TRUCKS
FROM RECYCLING INFRASTRUCTURE.
TO ABSORBING KABIN INTO FARMLAND
FROM JOBS IN WATER RECYCLING.
APPRENTICESHIPS FIXING BICYCLES
CALIFORNIANS CAN DO WELL BY
DOING GOOD.
MY GOAL IS TO HELP BRING STAFF
TOGETHER WITH WITHIN CALLIE PA
SO THAT WE CAN SHARE BEST
PRACTICES.
AVOID DUPLICATION STREAMLINED
PERMITTING PROCESSES AND
UNDERTAKE MULTIMEDIA ENFORCEMENT
ACTIONS.
BY GETTING BACK TO THE
FUNDAMENTALS OF STRATEGIC
PLANNING.
MANAGEMENT AND BUDGETING WE CAN
ASSURE ALL ACCOUNTABILITY.
CALIFORNIA'S GREATEST STRENGTH
IS OUR DIVERSITY AND I WILL
STRIVE TO MAKE CHAU ARE HIRING
REFLECTS THIS DIVESTITURE E..
I STRONGLY BELIEVE THAT THE
VALUES WE BRING TO OUR WELL.
BEING OPEN ACCEPTING RESPECTFUL
AND FOCUSED ON INTEGRITY ARE AS
IMPORTANT AS THE WORK WE DO.
DURING MY CAREER I'VE TRAVELED
TO EACH OF US STATE FIFTY EIGHT
COUNTIES.
VISITED MORE THAN A HUNDRED
TRIBAL NATIONS IN CALIFORNIA
WHAT CLOSELY WITH FAMAS
ENVIRONMENTAL ADVOCATES
ORGANIZED LABOR.
CLEAN TECH BUSINESSES LOCAL
GOVERNMENT AND THESE TO DEVELOP
TO DEVELOP THE LIVE UP PROGRAM'S
SUCCESSES.
OUR GOAL THE CALIBRATION
COLLUDING ACHIEVING THE HUMAN
RIGHT TO WATER.
BRINGING DOWN AS MY RATE
SIGNIFICANTLY REDUCING OUR
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS.
ENDING PLASTIC POLLUTION
CLEANING APOSTATES MOST TOXIC
SITES.
AND CREATING ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE FOR ALL.
BY DOING SO WE WILL BE HELPING
CALIFORNIANS ACHIEVE THEIR
DREAMS AND BE A BEACON TO THE
REST OF THE WORLD. TO SHOW WHAT
IS POSSIBLE.
BY LISTENING CAREFULLY TO THE
PEOPLE THAT WE SERVE WE CAN GAIN
THE COURAGE WISDOM AND STRENGTH
TO OVERCOME THE SIGNIFICANT
CHALLENGES THAT WE FACE.
I'M EXCITED TO WORK
COLLABORATIVELY WITH EACH OF YOU
IN THE ENTIRE LEGISLATURE. TO
ACHIEVE THESE GOALS THANK YOU I
LOOK FORWARD TO ANSWERING YOUR
QUESTIONS THIS AFTERNOON.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH LET ME START
WITH SENATOR MINING.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIRMAN.
WELCOME MR BLUMENFELD AND
CONGRATULATIONS ON YOUR
APPOINTMENT IN.
ON A VERY DISTINGUISHED CAREER.
I THINK WHEN WE TALKED YOU'VE
WORKED AT THE CITY LEVEL.
THE NATIONAL LEVEL.
IN NOW FINDING A HOME AT THE
STATE LEVEL.
YOU MADE REFERENCE IN YOUR
OPENING STATEMENT COMMITMENT.
TO SECURING CLEAN SAFE DRINKING
WATER IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
WE KNOW THERE'S ABOUT A MILLION
RESIDENTS WITHOUT WHAT'S WHAT'S
THE ROLE OF THE EPA.
IN SECURING THIS FUNDAMENTAL
HUMAN RIGHT.
THE VESSEL JUST CONTEXTUALLY I
MEAN IT'S KIND OF AMAZING THAT
IN TWENTY NINETEEN AND AND
MARLEY SHOCKING THAT WE WOULD
HAVE A MILLION PEOPLE IN THE
STATE AS WEALTHY AS OZ THAT
DON'T HAVE ACCESS TO SAFE AND
AFFORDABLE DRINKING WATER SO.
IT'S BOTH AND URBAN AND THE
RURAL PROBLEM --
IT IT IS FROM BOTH HISTORIC --
CONTAMINATION NITRATES AS WELL
AS NATURALLY OCCURRING --
SUBSTANCES LIKE ARSENIC IN
URANIUM SO IT RUNS THE GAMUT AND
AND REALLY THE GENESIS OF THE
PROBLEM IS THAT --
THE FACILITY THAT WE NEED IN
ORDER TO CLEAN THE WATER TO MAKE
IT SUITABLE PHùFOR DRINKING A
VERY VERY EXPENSIVE.
AND THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
PROVIDES THE STATE WITH MONEY
THAT ALLOWS US TO BUILD
INFRASTRUCTURE BUT WE DON'T HAVE
THE ABILITY TO PAY FOR THE
OPERATION AND MAINTENANCE.
OF THAT INFRASTRUCTURE SO
THERE'S A GAP AND THE VERY SMALL
COMMUNITIES OFTEN COMMUNITIES
LESS THAN THAN TWO HUNDRED
MEMBERS.
I'M DOESN'T HAVE THE ABILITY TO
PAY FOR THAT INFRASTRUCTURE IF
YOU THINK ABOUT DIVIDING EVEN A
SMALL BELL AMONG FORTY HOMES.
THE MATH DOESN'T WORK OUT SO
REALLY --
THIS ADMINISTRATION I KNOW IS IS
WORKING WITH YOU IN THE
LEGISLATURE. TO TO PUSH FORWARD --
SOLUTIONS THAT WOULD HELP FUND
NO THE OTHERS THAT HASN'T BEEN
LEGISLATED YET BUT THE PROPOSAL
IS TO TO TRY AND SEE ABOUT A
HUNDRED AND FORTY MILLION
DOLLARS A YEAR.
THROUGH DIFFERENT MEHODS TO
HELP PAY FOR THE OPERATION AND
MAINTENANCE BOTH AND EVAN AND
RURAL SETTINGS SO.
IT'S IT'S SOMETHING THAT WE WILL
NEED TO THINK ABOUT HOW WE DO --
WHEN I MEET WITH COMMUNITY
MEMBERS --
IT'S NOT JUST DRINKING IT'S
COOKING IT'S SHOWERING --
IT REALLY IS AT A STATE THAT WE
NEED TO MOVE BEYOND.
THANK YOU I APPRECIATE.
YOUR FOCUS ON THAT IN N IN THAT
EVERY YEAR AGENCY --
WHEN WE LOOK AT SOME OF THE
ENVIRONMENTAL THREATS FACING NOT
ONLY CALIFORNIA BUT THE PLANET
THROUGH CLIMATE CHANGE?
AIR QUALITY ISSUES.
A NEW ABNORMAL OF FIRES IN THE
IN THE STATE.
IN LOOKING AT SOME OF THE
ADVERSE IMPACTS.
OF CLIMATE CHANGE AIR QUALITY.
THEY OFTEN HIT HARDER ON
DISADVANTAGED MINORITY
COMMUNITIES.
WHAT DO YOU SEE THE CHALLENGES
IN YOUR AGENCY OF INCORPORATING
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE IN
MINORITY COMMUNITIES IN THE?
POLICIES AND PROGRAMS OF YOUR
AGENCY SO WITH THE CHALLENGES IN.
WHAT ARE THE OPPORTUNITIES WHAT
WHAT CAN YOUR?
TO MAKE YOUR APPROACH.
TO CLEAN ENVIRONMENT --
MORE INCLUSIVE.
WELL FIRST OF ALL THE THE
LEGISLATURE IN CALIFORNIA IS
REALLY LEAD ON THIS INITIATIVE
BOTH IN THE GREENHOUSE GAS
REDUCTION FONG CONTACTS AND IN
OTHER CONTEXTS.
IN SETTING ASIDE FUNDING TO MAKE
SURE THAT IT GOES TO
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES --
THE OPPORTUNITIES A GREAT --
THERE'S A LOT OF LOCAL KNOWLEDGE
A LOT OF I'M INTERESTED DESIRED
TO MOVE THE ON THE CURRENT STATE
OF ENVIRONMENTAL DIS.
KIND OF THIS REPAIR IN THESE
COMMUNITIES HAVE.
FROM MY PERSPECTIVE REALLY IT'S
ENGAGING COMMUNITIES LISTENING
TO COMMUNITIES VISITING WITH
COMMUNITIES AND WE THE THE
AGENCY THAT I A HELP OVERSEE.
HAVE LOTS OF DIFFERENT SUB
AGENCIES GETTING THEM ALL TO
WORK TOGETHER.
I'M ACROSS THE AGENCY AND THEN
GETTING THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
TO REALLY REALIZE THAT PEOPLE
WHO LIVE IN SMALL COMMUNITIES
THEY JUST SEE GOVERNMENT YOU
KNOW THEY SEE.
THEY DON'T DISTINGUISH THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENT STATE GOVERNMENT
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT SO IT'S
INCUMBENT ON US TO REALLY WORK
TOGETHER TO MAKE SURE THAT WITH
DELIVERING PROGRAMS IN A PLACE.
RATHER THAN JUST THINKING ABOUT.
YOU KNOW THESE WE NEED TO CLEAN
THE AIR WE NEED TO CLEAN THE AIR
IN OB IN CALIFORNIA BECAUSE IT
HAS THE WEST EQUALITY IN THE
NATION BY FAR --
SO THAT IS THE KIND OF AYE AYE
PLACE BASE INITIATIVE TO
SOMETHING THAT I BELIEVE AND
STRONGLY THE THE TWO MAIN LEVELS
THAT WE HAVE A FUNDING.
SO MAKING SURE ALL THAT THE
COMMUNITIES THAT NEED HELP MOST
GET HELP FAST.
AND THEN SECONDLY ENFORCEMENT
OFTEN IN THESE COMMUNITIES.
THESE LAWS THAT YOU'VE HELP
PASTA CONGRESS'S HELP HAAS I'M A
NOT ENFORCED ADEQUATELY SO
MAKING SURE THAT THE COMMUNITIES
THAT NEED THE HELP.
REALLY GET BOTH THE FUNDING AND
THE ENFORCEMENT SO THAT
BUSINESSES IN THOSE DISTRICTS NO
YOU KNOW WHAT THEY HAVE TO PLAY
BY THE SAME RULES.
AS BUSINESSES AND THE REST OF
THE STATE.
THE THE LAST ELEMENT THAT I
WOULD SAY IS REALLY MAKING SURE
THAT OUR PROCEDURES A WELCOMING
SOMETIMES IT'S INTIMIDATING.
THE COME TO SACRAMENTO I'M AND
VOICES ON THE HEAD AND AND
REALLY ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE IS
ABOUT.
BEING ON THE POLITICAL MARGINS
AND ON THOSE MARGINS WE NEED TO
BRING PEOPLE INTO THIS AND
ENCOURAGE THEM.
THAT THEY DO HAVE A A WILLING
PARTNER THAT IS GOING TO LISTEN
AND ACT.
ON THE ACTIONS THAT THEY SUGGEST
SO I THINK IT'S A IT'S A
CULTURAL.
ISSUE AND AND FROM MY
OBSERVATIONS CALIFORNIA'S DOING.
THE BEST JOB OF ANY STATE IN THE
NATION ON THIS ISSUE --
THE STILL A LOT TO DO.
THANK YOU I'M.
I COULD GO ON A LOT OF QUESTIONS
JUST BECAUSE I'VE ENJOYED OUR
INNER CHANGES AND JUST WHAT I
SEE IS A REAL.
VISION MATCHED WITH THE
ORGANIZATIONAL CAPACITY BUT I'M
LOOKING FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
YOU MADAM CHAIR THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SENATOR --
CENTER BATES.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR --
MR ROOM FIELD WE HAVE SUCH A
NICE DISCUSSION THE OTHER DAY
WHEN MY FIRST READING UP ON OF
THE YEAR --
COME INTO MY OFFICE BUT I HAD A
FEW FOLLOW UP AND I THINK I'VE
SHARE THAT WITH YOU.
AND I'D LIKE TO GO BACK TO THE
CLEAN WATER SAFE WATER AND THE
IMPACTS THAT WE SEE COMING FROM --
IN THE A COMMUNITY AND THEIR
CONCERNS WE REALLY NEED A
BALANCED AND I THINK WE SHARED.
OUR DISCUSSION ON THAT BUT YOU
DID INNOT ONE OF YOUR COMMENTS
Là.
OF MADE A COMMENT ABOUT LIMITING
THE NITRATE --
FROM OUT OF THE FERTILIZER THAT
FARMERS CAN USE AND I I'M
LOOKING AT THAT AND WONDERING
HOW YOU MIGHT ACCOMPLISH THAT
THERE ARE BE SEVERAL MEANS
OBVIOUSLY FEES TAXES OR SOME
SORT OF RATIONING OR LIMITING OF
OF FERTILIZER USE COULD YOU.
EXPAND ON THAT ARE A COMMUTER I
WOULD LIKE TO HEAR ON THE RECORD
SOME COMMENTS.
ABOUT THE MEANS BY WHICH WE CAN
APPROACH THAT BUT IT CERTAINLY --
IN IN TERMS OF PROTECTING BOTH
SIDES OF THE ISSUE.
THAT EIGHT AFTER THE DEBATE.
THE ISSUE OF HOW OLD THAT
HUNDRED FORTY MILLION --
IS ARRIVED AT IS IS OBVIOUSLY A
LEGISLATIVE ISSUE --
IN TIME TO THE PRESENT
LEGISLATION THAT THAT --
OF THE SENATE A MONNING IS OF IS
AN EXPERT ON THIS BUT I'LL I'LL
SPEAK.
BRIEFLY TO THE GENESIS OF THE
AGREEMENT BETWEEN THE AG
COMMUNITY PARTICULARLY IN THE
SAN JOAQUIN.
I'M AND THE ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE AND FARM WORK A
COMMUNITY THERE'S AN AGREEMENT
THAT.
THAT HAD BEEN LEGACY NITRATE
POLLUTION NO ONE DISAGREES ABOUT
ISSUES --
THE QUESTION IS. TWO FOLD ONE
HOW HOW TO PHAM IS GET SHORTY
THAT IF THEY'RE IN CURRENT
COMPLIANCE WITH THE LAW.
THAT THEY WON'T BE SUBJECT TO
ENFORCEMENT ACTIONS THAT DEAL
WITH THE HISTORIC POLLUTION AND
SECONDLY HOW DO WE FIND --
DRINKING WATER --
FULL DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES
AND SO THE COMPROMISE OF THESE
GROUPS WHICH IS REALLY HAS STARK
IN CALIFORNIA AND I WANT TO GIVE
A LOT OF PRAISE TO THEM.
WHATEVER THE EVENTUAL OUTCOME
THEY CAME TO LOT LET'S ENDEL
THIS ANTAGONISM AND M. IF WE PUT
A FEE ON FERTILIZES.
THAT ARRIVES AT ABOUT THIRTY
MILLION DOLLARS A YEAR IN
EXCHANGE THERE WILL BE A
PROVISION TO HOLD.
LEGACY CONTAMINATION FROM
NITRATES HARMLESS --
WHERE THOSE --
FARMERS ARE IN COMPLIANCE WITH
THAT CURRENT REGIMES OUT IS
ACTUALLY OF A PRETTY AMAZING
COMPROMISE I'M GONNA GIVES ME A
LOT OF I'M POLLS TO TO FEEL GOOD
ABOUT OUR ABILITY TO SELL THESE
COMPLEX ISSUES BECAUSE WHEN
FARMERS AND FARM WORKERS COME
TOGETHER AND COME OUT WITH THESE
SOLUTIONS.
IT'S IT'S ALL FOR THE BETTER
SAYS.
I'M IN IN TERMS OF GOING FORWARD
SENATE -- WE
DO NEED TO MAKE SURE ALL THAT WE
KEEPING A WATCHFUL EYE AND
WORKING CLOSELY WITH COMMAS TO
MAKE SURE ALL.
THAT CURRENT PESTICIDE USE ISN'T
POLLUTING FUTURE GROUND WATER
BECAUSE AS WE FOUND OUT THIS IS
EXTRAORDINARILY EXPENSIVE.
EXTRAORDINARILY EXPENSIVE TO FIX --
AND WILL ALSO NEED TO SHOWN THE
THE COMPANIES THAT MAKE THEM
THAT THE WE WANT TO LOOK FOR
ALTERNATIVES THAT ON TOXIC TO
GROUND WATER.
THANK YOU I'LL WE ALL LIVE THE
WORD COMPROMISE THAT'S HOW WE
GET GOOD POLICY AND ARE
CERTAINLY GREAT LEADERS HELP US
GET THERE LIKE.
THE LEADERSHIP YOU'RE GOING TO
TAKE OVER AT KELLY PA ONE LAST
QUESTION I HAVE IS FOCUSING ON
THE HOUSING --
CONCERNS THE AND OBVIOUSLY TO
SEE CLARA.
AND ALL I KNOW AND I WAS --
PART OF ON NEVA YOU ARE AWARE
THE DON'T ALLOW ANONYMOUS --
CHALLENGES UNDER NEPA.
WOULD YOU BE OPEN TO
ENTERTAINING THAT OUT FOR SEQUEL
LAWSUITS WHICH CURRENTLY CAN BE
FILED ANONYMOUSLY.
ARE THAT IS SOMETHING THAT IS
NOT BE ALWAYS BASED IN THE
COMMUNITY --
WHERE THE IMPACTS ARE HAPPENING
IT CAN BE OUTSIDE AGENCIES FOR
WHATEVER PURPOSE WE WOULD HOPE
IT'S ENVIRONMENTAL BUT MANY
TIMES WE FOUND THAT IT'S NOT
NECESSARILY THAT SO COULD YOU?
ADDRESS THAT AND YOUR THOUGHTS
ON THAT HAVING SERVED IN ALL
WHEN AGENCY THAT DOESN'T ALLOW
IT AND COMING TO ANOTHER ONE
THAT THAT STILL DOES.
YEAH I'M I'M NOT FLUENT ENOUGH --
TO BE ABLE TO UNDERSTAND THE
GENESIS OF WHY ONE SYSTEM HAS
AND A NUMBER THE MAYBE IT'S A
WHISTLEBLOWER PROTECTIONS ON
OPTIONAL WHAT THE THE REASONS
ARE BACK.
DOZEN TIMES OF THESE ACTS WHICH
GET A LOT OF ATTENTION RELIEF
FOR ME THE THE MAN GOAL IS IS
TO LOOK AT ENVIRONMENTAL
TENTATIVE --
AND THEY'VE YOU KNOW THEY'VE
MORPHED INTO DIFFERENT THINGS
OVER TIME BUT THE REAL GOAL IS
TO SAY.
THIS IS THE PROPOSED PROJECT
OTHER OUT OF THE ARE THERE
IMPACTS TO THAT.
ENVIRONMENTAL IMPACTS ON THAT
PROJECT AND IS THERE AN ABILITY
TO COME OUT WITH A CLEAR SIGHTED
VIEW OF ALTERNATIVES AND TO ME
THAT'S THE THE ROOT OF BOTH THE
NATIONAL ENVIRONMENTAL POLICY
ACT AND AND SEA QUEST.
AND YET AS ACTIVITY I TOLD ABOUT
OUTSIDE OF GOVERNMENT BETWEEN
HOME BUILDERS.
AND ORGANIZED LABOR AND
ENVIRONMENTAL GROUPS TO LOOK AT
HOW THE HOW TO THINK ABOUT THIS
IN THE HOUSING CONTACTS
INSTANTLY.
IF US TO PLAY A ROLE IN THAT
WILL WILL BE CONSTRUCTIVE IN.
IN TRYING TO MEET THOSE TWIN
GOALS -- I
WAS THE PROCESS YOU KNOW WE ARE
INVOLVED IN PROCESS LADEN.
WHACK AND AND AND MY GOAL WITHIN
CALLIE PA IS TO REALLY LOOK AT
WHAT THE VALUE PROPOSITION WHERE
WE WHERE WE GETTING MEANINGFUL
ENVIRONMENTAL GAINS.
AS OPPOSED TO IN MANY
COMMUNITIES THAT JUST FEELING
LIKE THAT IS CONTINUOUS
REGULATION THAT DOESN'T PROVIDE
GAINES SO I'M GONNA LOOK FOR
WAYS OF CREATING EFFICIENCY.
I'M STARTING IN THE PHAM
COMMUNITIES I'VE MET WITH COMMAS
AND EACH INDIVIDUAL PIECE OF
REGULATION MAY MAKE SENSE BUT
WHEN YOU ALL INDIVIDUAL FARMER
IT'S TOUGH.
WHEN IT'S?
BUT THREE ALLOWED A BOX AND IT'S
VERY THICK SO.
I'M I THINK WE NEED TO WE NEED.
TO KEEP THE INTEGRITY M. OF THE
PROTECTIONS BUT HELP. TO MAKE
THE PROCESS MORE EFFICIENT.
THANK YOU FOR LOW FLORA
RESPONSES SO RIGHT ON APPRECIATE
THAT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SENATOR BATES LET ME --
HEAD OVER TO SENATOR ROTH.
THANK YOU MAYOR PRO TEM.
NO QUESTIONS REALLY JUST A
COUPLE COMMENTS BUT FIRST A SIR
LET ME CONGRATULATE YOU ON YOUR
A NOMINATION I WANTED GENERALLY
SAY THAT I'VE BEEN VERY VERY
IMPRESSED WITH THE QUALITY OF
THE NOMINEES.
PUT FORWARD BY THIS GOVERNOR AND
THEN FELL YOU ARE CERTAINLY NO
EXCEPTION OPTIONALLY WELL
QUALIFIED I I HAD THE WE HAD THE
PRIVILEGE OF HAVING A A WIDE
RANGING CONVERSATION AND IN MY
OFFICE ABOUT.
KELLY PA'S CHALLENGES THE
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS PROGRAM
AND METRICS DE TSC.
AND PERHAPS MOST IMPORTANTLY
GIVEN.
OF WHERE IT IS ON THE PRIORITY
AROUND HERE IN THE BUILDING
WATER QUALITY ISSUES AND
SOLUTIONS.
AS YOU KNOW I HAVE SOME GENERAL
CONCERNS --
SURROUNDING THE IMPOSITION OF A
WIDELY BASED WATER FEE BUT I I
RECOGNIZE CLEARLY THAT THERE IS
A PROBLEM AND THAT WE NEED TO
ARRIVE AT A SOLUTION.
SO I LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
WITH YOU.
TO TALK ABOUT THE FUNDING A
PROPOSALS THAT COME FORWARD AND
ALTERNATIVES TO THOSE AND
TOGETHER WITH MY COLLEAGUES IN
THE GOVERNOR --
WE WILL FIND A SOLUTION TO THIS
PROBLEM SO CONGRATULATIONS AGAIN
AND I LOOK FORWARD TO MOVING
YOUR A NOMINATION AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME.
THANK YOU SIR.
THANK YOU MISTER VICE CHAIRMAN.
THANK YOU A MAN PRO TEM I
THOROUGHLY ENJOYED OUR
CONVERSATION AND I'M GLAD YOU'RE
AS EXCITED AS I AM ABOUT
INDUSTRIAL HAVE.
AND THERE'S BEEN A REVOLUTION OR
EXCITED NOW.
AS YOU SHOULD BE AND NOT ALWAYS
GONNA REVOLUTIONIZE AGRICULTURE
IN CALIFORNIA BUT LESS WATER THE
MOST CROPS.
THE PRESSURES CARBON LITTLE TO
NO PESTICIDES BECAUSE IT
LITERALLY IS A WEED AND OUR
REMEDIATE READ REMEDIATE THE
SOIL AND I HOPE YOU CAN COME
DOWN AND JOIN ME IN APRIL WHEN
WE PLANT THE FIRST INTERNATIONAL
HAVE BEEN CALIFORNIA MY DISTRICT --
I KNOW NOW I'M A NOW VALLEY SO
IT'S BEEN FOR A HUNDRED SINCE
NINETEEN THIRTIES BIN AND A
VALLEY FAIR ENOUGH SOUTH OF
POSSIBLE I SEE A DAY WHEN IS
THAT VALLEY FAIR AND HIM
FESTIVAL.
BE GOOD FOR A TOURISM
[inaudible]
TO HEY HI [inaudible]
FLETCHER.
ANYWAY SINCE WE SINCE WE MET
THERE WAS A A POLITICAL ARTICLES
LIKE I WANT TO KIND OF FOLLOW UP
ON THAT SO.
IN THAT YOU MENTIONED THAT YOUR
INTEREST ABOVE --
CARBON EMISSIONS AND GLOBAL
WARMING IS IS --
THE YOU KNOW.
AIR QUALITY AS IT PERTAINS LIKE
OZONE AND A AND PM AND SO I'M
JUST WONDERING WHAT YOUR
STRATEGY IS GOING TO BE TO TRY
TO GET US INTO ATTAINMENT.
THAT'S A GREAT QUESTION YEAH SO
BASICALLY MY EMPHASIS I'M.
IS REALLY TO TO LOOK AT
COMMUNITY NEEDS I'M AND WHEN YOU
LOOK AT THE CLEAN AIR ACT --
CALIFORNIA OBVIOUSLY WAS A
PRECURSOR TO THE CLEAN AIR ACT
BACK IN THE NINETEEN SIXTIES.
THE LA BASIN HAD SUCH POOR AIR
QUALITY THAT PUSH THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT AND NINETEEN SEVENTY
PRESIDENT NIXON SIGNED INTO LAW
THE CLEAN AIR ACT SO.
FROM THAT POINT UNTIL NOW WE
HAVE NOT ATTAINED.
I'M COMPLIANCE WITH THE FEDERAL
CLEAN AIR ACT --
AND EIGHT THOUSAND PLUS PEOPLE
DIE YET JUST FROM PM TWO POINT
FIVE EXPOSURE.
SAYS. EIGHT IT'S NOT AN EITHER
OR IT'S YOU KNOW WHEN WE'RE
LOOKING AT WHAT WE CAN DO. TO TO
REDUCE GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS
LET'S FOCUS ON THE THINGS THAT
ALSO REDUCE CRITERIA POLLUTANTS
LIKE KNOX.
I'M SAID EXAMPLE BE YOU KNOW
THAT PHAM EQUIPMENT IN THE SAN
JOAQUIN VALLEY IF YOU CAN REDUCE.
I'M THE EMISSIONS FROM VERY OLD
FARM EQUIPMENT THAT HELPS YOU
KNOW THE PHARMACY SAVE MONEY I'M
IT'S A MUCH MORE EFFICIENT
VEHICLES SO IT'S LESS POLLUTION.
ABOUT GREENHOUSE GASES AND
CRITERIA POLLUTANTS AND IT HELPS
THE COMMUNITIES SURROUNDING.
THEM SO REALLY IT'S THAT WAS OF
A VERY APPROPRIATE FOCUS ON ON
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS.
I THINK I AM WE NEED TO RE
ENGAGE A LITTLE BIT MORE ON THE
CRITERIA POLLUTANTS I'M AND TO
YOUR QUESTION IT'S IT'S VERY.
THE THE TARGETS IN THE CLEAN AIR
ACT VERY AGGRESSIVE FROM A WHEN
YOU LOOK AT THE ASH ADD IN BOTH
SOUTH COAST AND THE SAN JOAQUIN.
YOU KNOW THAT A LOT OF POLLUTION
JUST MOVES UP AGAINST THE FOOT
HILLS AND IT AND IT GETS TRACKED
THAT SO.
THEY HAVE THE MOST AGGRESSIVE --
CLEAN AIR LAWS IN THE WORLD IN
THOSE AREAS BUT WE FRANKLY HAVE
TO DO MORE ON ON THINGS LIKE
WOOD STOVES --
IN THE SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY AND IN
THE CASE OF SOUTH BECAUSE REALLY
DOES NEED TO LOOK AT COMBUSTION
ACROSS THE BOARD WHETHER IT'S
MOVING FREIGHT --
AS WE TALKED ABOUT 41% OF UNITED
STATES CUMMINS COMES INTO THE
SAN PEDRO PARKS --
WE CANNOT WE CAN MAKE THAT A LOT
OF THAT.
ZERO THAT.
WHEN YOU MAKE SOMETHING ZERO
EMISSIONS NEAR THE PORT?
IT'S HELPING THOSE PORT
COMMUNITIES.
AND REDUCING GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS WHERE THAT OTHER OF
THE MISSIONS WHICH IS JUST
PURELY GREENHOUSE GAS RELATED
THAT ON HELPING COMMUNITIES AS
MUCH SO.
THE MY GOAL BE TO LOOK AT THE
INTERSECTION OF THOSE.
SO I I HAVE ONE FOLLOW COULD
JUST TO KIND OF YOU LISTED IT
IT'S SO I WOULD SO FARM BUREAU
SECTOR THIS WEEK SO I KNOW THIS
IS TRUE I WAS TALKING WITH A
GENTLEMAN LAST NIGHT.
AND HE SAID IN TERMS OF THE THE
DIESEL IT ENGINE ENGINES AT THE
USE AND AND FARMING EQUIPMENT.
THAT THE THE FUNDING THIS YEAR
IS DOWN FROM WHAT IT'S BEEN FROM
THE PRIOR ADMINISTRATION IN
TERMS OF BEING ABLE TO YOU KNOW
CHANGE OUT THOSE.
THOSE ENGINES SAID TO MAKE IT
YOU KNOW RIGHT LESS YOU KNOW.
THIS CHARGE WAS POLLUTANTS IS
THAT IS THAT TRUE AND IS THERE A
WAY CONSIDERING.
THE BUDGET SURPLUS WE'RE GONNA
HAVE THAT WE CAN MAYBE RE
PRIORITIZE THAT.
AS AN ADDITIONAL SEVENTY
SOMETHING THAT I'M ENGAGED
ACTIVELY IN DISCUSSING.
RIGHT GREAT AGAIN LOOKING FOR TO
VOTING FOR YOU AND
CONGRATULATIONS.
THANK YOU MISTER VICE CHAIRMAN I
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR BEING HERE
HI.
I JUST WANT.
TO COVER A COUPLE OF THINGS
MOSTLY AS COMMENTS BECAUSE MY
COLLEAGUES HAVE ASK.
OUR RELEVANT QUESTIONS I
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
MEET WITH YOU YESTERDAY --
EXTENSIVELY TO GO OVER THE LONG
LIST OF THE CRITICAL ISSUES.
THAT YOU ARE WILL OVERSEE AND
OUR MOST CRITICAL DEPARTMENTS AT
THIS AND THEY'RE ALL REALLY
IMPORTANT.
DEPARTMENTS I I REALLY
APPRECIATE THE COMMENTS ON THE
CLIMATE TARGETS AND COMPLIANCE.
AND THE FACT THAT THE QUESTIONS
ASKED BY MY COLLEAGUES ABOUT --
THE LOWER INCOME COMMUNITIES I
IMPACTED COMMUNITIES AG AREAS
AND HOW TO SUPPORT
I AND AND THAT THOSE THOSE
ISSUES AROUND RESOURCES AND
FUNDING WE WILL TAKE UP DURING%
THE BUDGET CONVERSATIONS.
AS IT RELATES TO THE CAP AND
TRADE DOLLARS --
AND OTHER THINGS SO I LOOK
FORWARD TO THAT DISCUSSION.
HI AND MAKING SURE THAT WE
CONTINUE --
TO USE THOSE RESOURCES IN A FAIR
AND EQUITABLE WAY WITH OF
VARIOUS COMMUNITIES INCLUDING.
I AG COMMUNITIES FARMING EXCEPT
TRUCK.
AS WELL AS URBAN COMMUNITIES
WHERE THERE ARE DISADVANTAGED
AND AND THE PROGRAMS THAT
SUPPORT.
THOSE AT WE DIDN'T HAVEN'T
TALKED ABOUT THIS MAYBE THIS
BECAUSE I AM THE BORDER
REPRESENTATIVE OUT WELL AS CLOSE
AS CAN BE --
WE YOU JUST BRIEFLY --
TO THE CHALLENGES ALONG THE
BORDER -- IT
DIDN'T HAVE TO BE EXTENSIVE BUT
THE THE FOCUS ON SOME OF THE
WORK WE'RE DOING ABOUT CROSS
BORDER ISSUES AROUND A NUMBER OF
ISSUES THAT WE TALKED ABOUT.
AS TO THE THE BORDER THE U. S.
MEXICO BORDER GETS A LOT OF
ATTENTION A LOT OF IT ISN'T
ABOUT THE ENVIRONMENT BUT IF.
YOU LIVE ON EITHER SIDE OF THAT
BORDER THE ENVIRONMENT TO VERY.
BIG FOCAL POINT.
SAYS MAYBE START WITH THE WATER
ISSUES.
ALL THE RIVER AS INTO THE US IN
IN CALIFORNIA FLOW FROM SOUTH TO
NORTH WE OFTEN THINK THAT
THEY'RE GONNA FLY THE OTHER
DIRECTION BACK.
FROM THE NEW RIVER TO THE
TIJUANA RIVER --
THOSE THE THE POLLUTION THAT'S
COMING FROM MEXICO INTO THE U.
S. IS A VERY SIGNIFICANT
CHALLENGES IN SAN DIEGO SADLY ON
THE BEACH CLOSURES.
YOU KNOW FROM SEWAGE IN TIJUANA
IT'S SOMETHING --
THAT WAS A BIG CONCERN OF MINE
AT UNITED STATES ENVIRONMENTAL
PROTECTION AGENCY AND AND WE PUT
HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS OF DOLLARS.
INTO WASTE WATER TREATMENT I'M
IT'S GETTING BETTER IT'S
CERTAINLY NOT GOOD ENOUGH AND WE
NEED A LOT OF CROSS BORDER
COLLABORATION TO MAKE THAT
HAPPEN.
NOT ONLY IS THIS SEWAGE BUT IF
YOU GO INTO THE T. O. YOU KNOW
YOU'RE WALKING ON FIVE OR SIX
FEET OF TRASH ON THE ALL FEET --
AND YOU KNOW THE AS CALIFORNIANS
IS SOMEONE THAT HAS A LOT ABOUT
THE OCEAN.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT THAT PACIFIC
GARBAGE PATCH A LOT OF THAT IS
COMING YOU KNOW FROM FROM THAT
PART OF?
OUR STATE --
SO ONE OF THE THINGS WE'RE WE'RE
LOOKING AT IS CLOSER
COLLABORATION WITH BOTH BAJA AND
MEXICO CITY TO TO TREAT THESE
ISSUES IN A IN A SERIOUS WAY.
I'M ON THE NEW RIVER --
THE NEW REVISED FEEDS RIGHT INTO
THE SELDOM SEE.
THE SALTY OBVIOUSLY IS A VERY
HIGH PRIORITY FOR THIS
ADMINISTRATION.
THE THE WATER GOING INTO THE
SALTON SEA FROM THE NEW RIVER IS
VERY TOXIC THERE'S A PROGRAM
THAT WE HAVE TO LOOK AT PIPING
IT.
SO THAT THE FUMES ON EXPOSING
NEIGHBORS --
IN CALEXICO AND THEN THE IN
IMPERIAL COUNTY IMPERIAL COUNTY
HAS VERY SIGNIFICANT ISSUES AT A
SIZEABLE NUMBER OF THOSE COME
FROM.
MEXICO A SIZEABLE NUMBER OF
THOSE ALSO COME FROM IMPERIAL
COUNTIES SO.
SOMETIMES CONVENIENT TO BLAME
MEXICO BUT WE ALSO NEED TO MAKE
SURE OUR OWN HOUSES IN ORDER.
I'M.
SO WHEN THE THE AIR RESOURCES
BOARD HAS SENT MONITORS.
AND MONITORS AND WHAT WE FOUND
IS IT'S A LOT OF TRASH BANNING.
I'M IN --
MEXICALI AND AND SO COMING OUT
WITH JUST SIMPLE WASTE
MANAGEMENT PRACTICES COULD
SIGNIFICANTLY HELP THE AIR
QUALITY IN CALIFORNIA.
I ANI I APPRECIATE I YOUR
EXPERIENCE AND I WILL SAY --
IT WAS REALLY AN ENJOYABLE
ALMOST OUR TALKING TO ABOUT ALL
OF THESE ISSUES AND THE
UNDERSTANDING.
THAT YOU HAVE IN THE DEEP DIVE
ON SO MANY ISSUES FROM.
THE CLIMATE TARGETS BORDER
POLLUTION RECYCLING WHICH I WILL
NOT.
I WILL NOT DO TO YOU TODAY --
BECAUSE I THINK WE HAD A LONG
CONVERSATION ABOUT THE
CHALLENGES THAT WE ARE GOING TO
NEED TO MEET.
IN THAT ARENA BUT THE EIGHT THAT
YOU HAVE AN UNDERSTANDING OF OF
THE BROAD GLOBAL ISSUES AROUND
WHAT WE'RE GONNA HAVE TO DO IN
CALIFORNIA.
I AGREE WITH MY COLLEAGUE --
SENATOR ROTH ON ISSUES AROUND
THE WATER FIX AND IN PARTICULAR
AS THIS ADMINISTRATION PROCEEDS
WITH OUR WITH ITS REVISIONS.
ARE I WANT TO BE SURE THAT.
YOU KNOW WE'RE ABLE TO BE KEPT
CLOSELY IN THE LOOP AS IT
RELATES TO OUR WATER AGENCIES IN
PARTICULARLY I'M CONCERNED ABOUT.
SAN DIEGO OF COURSE ARE THE
CONFIGURATION AND THE COST OF
THE PROJECT I THINK.
MANY OF US WANT TO SEE HOW THAT
PROCEEDS.
AND IT WILL YEAH AGAIN THESE ARE
ALL CRITICALLY IMPORTANT ISSUES
THAT'S WHY I THINK YOU SEE SO
MANY PEOPLE IN THE ROOM TODAY.
AND I THINK IT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT TO PUT ON THE RECORD
FOR THE PUBLIC BECAUSE WE SPEND
EACH OF US.
ARE QUITE A BIT A TOM PRIOR TO
THIS MEETING TO MAKE SURE WE PUT
ON YOUR RADAR SCREEN THE ISSUES
THAT ARE MOST IMPORTANT TO OUR
CONSTITUENTS IN THE MOST
INTERESTING THING IS.
MOST OF THESE ISSUES ARE
STATEWIDE WE MAY COME AT IT FROM
A DIFFERENT PERSPECTIVE
REGIONALLY ON ANY NUMBER OF
THESE ISSUES BUT ULTIMATELY.
I EVERY SINGLE ONE OF THE ISSUES
THAT YOU OVERSEE WITHIN THE
VARIOUS DEPARTMENTS OUR STATE
WIDE ISSUES AT SOME LEVEL SO IT
MAKES IT A LOT MORE COMPLICATED
I THINK.
BUT YOUR EXPERIENCE YOUR
EXPERTISE YOUR KNOWLEDGE AND
YOUR ABILITY TO REALLY ENGAGE IN
SUBSTANTIVE CONVERSATIONS WE ARE
VERY FORTUNATE --
THAT THE GOVERNOR WAS ABLE.
TO MAKE DISAPPOINTMENT AND WITH
THAT I CONCUR WITH THE COMMENTS
OF MY COLLEAGUES.
AND WILL ASK IF THERE IS ANYONE
HERE ARE IN SUPPORT THAT WOULD
LIKE TO COME FORWARD THERE IS A
MICROPHONE.
AND IN THE INTEREST OF HOW MANY
PEOPLE ARE NOW SEE STANDING UP.
LET ME SUGGEST YOUR NAME WHO YOU
REPRESENT.
AND EIGHTY SHORT COUPLE OF
SENTENCES DON'T FOLLOW MY MODEL
A SHORT COUPLE OF SENTENCES --
IN TERMS OF YOUR THANK YOU.
GOVERNMENT WOULD FOR CLEANER
NGUYEN WHOSE YES AGREE SUPPORT
THE CONFIRMATION OF SECRETARY
BLUMENFELD WE ESPECIALLY
APPRECIATE HIS FOCUS ON THE
IMPLEMENTATION AND ENFORCEMENT
OF OUR AIR QUALITY STANDARDS.
AND LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
HIM TO FULFILL GOVERNOR
NEWSOME'S PLEDGE TO SET
CALIFORNIA ON A FAST TRACK TO
ZERO DIESEL POLLUTION BY.
TWENTY THIRTY EXCELLENT MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
POLITICS READ --
ON BEHALF OF QUITE A FEW CLIENTS
ACTUALLY ARE PEOPLE DON'T
REALIZE HOW MUCH KALLI PAN
COMPASSES EVERYTHING THAT WE DO
EVERYTHING FROM OUR E. V. SEMI
TRUCKS COMING OUT. TO SEE TO SEE
A MAYES CONCERNED ABOUT ASTHMA
TO MY PLASTIC RECYCLERS WHO
TRIED TO KEEP PLASTIC OUT OF
LANDFILLS.
AND AS IMPORTANT THE TRIBES SO
THE TRIBES THAT I REPRESENT
WORKED REALLY HARD ON AB FIFTY
TWO AND THE SACRED SITES ISSUES
THOSE VOLUNTARY PA.
TOO SO WE COMMEND THE GOVERNOR
ON ANOTHER GREAT APOINTMENT AND
WHEN IT'S NICE TO SEE SOMEONE
WHO I THINK CAN BALANCE BOTH
BUSINESS AND ENVIRONMENT ALONG
WITH TRAVEL GOVERNMENTS THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU.
HI CAITLYN CLUE I HEAR JUST
PROVIDE A HEARTY --
ME TOO AND LARGE SUPPORT FOR
GERRY BLOOM FELT AS POTENTIAL
SECRETARY CALIFORNIA APA ON
BEHALF THIS OF WRITER FOUNDATION
THE CALIFORNIA COASTAL
PROTECTION NETWORK ENTERED
JUSTICE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS CHRIS
KARMA PARTNERED BAKER BOTTS LAW
FIRM IN SAN FRANCISCO.
I'VE KNOWN MR BLUMENFELD FOR
TWENTY YEARS BOTH IN AND OUT OF
GOVERNMENT WORK TOGETHER ON A
NUMBER OF PROJECTS.
AND I REALLY REPRESENT HEAVILY
REGULATED INDUSTRIES IN FACT
MADAM CHAIR I I ENJOYED REMARKS
AT THE CFA.
RECEPTION LAST WEEK I DO A LOT
WITH AG DO A LOT WITH MY NAME
AND MR BLUMENFELD IS TRULY A
STUDENT OF THE ADMINISTRATIVE
LAW PROCESS.
AND THE REGULATORY PROCESS AND
THE POLICY GOALS THERE'S NO ONE
BETTER IN THE STATE TO PURSUE
THEM FOR OUR STATE.
BUT JERRY MY EXPERIENCE KNOWS
THAT THOSE GOALS CAN BE
ACCOMPLISHED WITHOUT A
GOVERNMENT SYSTEM THAT DELIVERS
BOTH FOR THE REGULATED AND FOR
THE PUBLIC AND SO HIS FOCUS THAT
HE HAD AN EPA.
REGION DIED I KNOW HOW BRING IT
HERE AND DELIVER FOR BOTH THE
REGULATED COMMUNITY AND THE
PUBLIC AT LARGE THANK YOU
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS JENNIFER FEARING HERE
TODAY INTO THE ASPECTS SUPPORT
OF SECRETARY BLUMENFELD
APPOINTMENT FOR DEFENDERS OF
WILDLIFE THE CENTER FOR FOOD
SAFETY.
AND THE PESTICIDE ACTION NETWORK
WHO IN HIS VERY SHORT TIME HERE
OUR EXPERIENCE WITH HIM WE FOUND
HIM TO BE FULL OF INTEGRITY.
AND CANDOR ACCESSIBILITY AND
EXPERIENCE SO WE'RE GRATEFUL TO
THE GOVERNOR FOR NOMINATING HIM
THANK YOU.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS PAT RAN WITH
THEIR AND READING ASSOCIATES
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF PROFESSIONAL
SCIENTISTS IN THE PROFESSIONAL
ENGINEERS IN CALIFORNIA
GOVERNMENT.
BOTH WHO HAVE MEMBERS AT WORKING
KALECKI AA --
WE SUPPORT THE APPOINTMENT AND
THE CONFIRMATION OF THE
SECRETARY BLOOM WE LOOK FORWARD
TO WORKING WITH HIM THANK YOU
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON JAMIE GO ON
BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA RELIEF AND
STRONG SUPPORT OF SECRETARY
BLUMENFELD CONFIRMATION WE LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH HIM IN
THE COMING YEAR ON INVESTMENTS.
TO FOR CLIP DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES FOR CRIME ADAPTATION
AND RESILIENCE THANK YOU THANK
YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR RICO
MONSTER TO NOT A WITH THE TRUST
FOR PUBLIC LAND.
THIS IS INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT
AGENCY TO THE STATE AND TO OUR
GOALS.
AND WE COULDN'T BE MORE EXCITED
ABOUT YOUR APPOINTMENT A
SECRETARY BLUMENFELD SO IN
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
MADAM PRO TEM MEMBERS THE
COMMITTEE.
LOUIS BROWN ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA COTTON GROWERS IN
JENNER'S ASSOCIATION THE NIECE A
FARMER'S LEAGUE.
AMERICANS TO STASH YOUR GROWERS
AND THE STRAWBERRY COMMISSION
TODAY.
IN FAVOR AND IN SUPPORT OF MR
BLUMENFELD HIS APPOINTMENT THIS
MAY BE THE FIRST TIME --
THAT I'VE COME BEFORE THIS
COMMITTEE SUPPORT THE
CONFIRMATION OF A SECRETARY FOR
THE ENVIRONMENTAL PROTECTION
AGENCY.
AND I THINK THAT GOES TO SAY A
LOT ABOUT THE RELATIONSHIP MR
BLUMENFELD HAS CREATED WITH THE
AG INDUSTRY --
IN HIS YEARS IN PROFESSIONAL
SERVICE --
HE'S DEDICATED SIGNIFICANT
AMOUNT OF TIME TO THE ISSUES
THAT ARE IMPORTANT TO US THE SAN
JOAQUIN VALLEY IN THE STATE AS A
WHOLE WE LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
WITH HIM THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU TERM MEMBERS NUCLEAR
CROWDED WITH THE NATURAL
RESOURCES DEFENSE COUNCIL ALSO
REGISTRY SUPPORT FOR THE
CALIFORNIA LEGAL CONSERVATION
VOTERS.
BECAUSE YOU HAVE TO CLEAN
SUPPORT OF MR BLUMENFELD
NOMINATION AT RTC IN OUR STOP OF
WORKED WITH HIM FOR OVER TWO
DECADES ON A WIDE VARIETY OF
ISSUES AND I IN A RANGE OF HIS
FORMER LEADERSHIP ROLES --
AND WE BELIEVE IS AN EFFECTIVE
AND INNOVATIVE ADMINISTRATOR
WHETHER IT'S DIESEL POLLUTION
DRINKING WATER QUALITY OR
PESTICIDE EXPOSURE AMONG FARM
WORKER COMMUNITIES.
WE'RE VERY EXCITED TO WORK WITH
THEM OVER THE NEXT YEAR THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
CENTERS OF THE COMMITTEE I'LL
FEDERAL NO WARNING LOCAL HATS --
FIRST OFF ON BEHALF ENVIRONMENT
DEFENSE FUND VERY MUCH IN STRONG
SUPPORT YOUR RECORD SPEAKS FOR
ITSELF WE KNOW THE VALUE THAT
YOU WILL BRING TO TO THE AGENCY
AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
WITH YOU ON CLIMATE CHANGE
ISSUES WRIT LARGE.
AND EVERYTHING ELSE --
UNDER YOUR PER --
A A ORGANIZATION DEDICATED TO TO
IMPROVING ACCESS TO THE OUTDOORS
FOR DIVERSE COMMUNITIES --
WITH A REALLY STRONG EMPHASIS
AND DESIRE TO CONTINUE WORKING
ON THE ENVIRONMENT AND THE AND
EDUCATION AND THE ENVIRONMENT
INITIATIVE UNDERCARRIAGE CYCLE --
TO TO REALLY JUST URSUE
ADDITIONAL ACCESS TO THE
MATERIALS THAT AND THAT ALL OF
OUR STUDENTS IN CALIFORNIA NEED
IN ORDER TO BE ABLE TO
UNDERSTAND AND GRASP THE THE
ISSUES THAT WILL BE GRAPPLING
WITH FOR THE NEXT DECADES TO
COME.
ON BEHALF OF US SOON YOUR
EXPERIENCE WORKING ON MARINE
PLASTIC POLLUTION ISSUES --
HAS REALLY EXCITED ABOUT BEING
ABLE TO ENGAGE WITH YOU AND YOUR
STAFF AND CONTINUE THE HARD WORK --
BOTH IN YOU KNOW TO POTENTIAL
LEGISLATION BUT ALSO AT THE
ADMINISTRATIVE LEVEL --
TO ENSURE THAT WE CAN CONTINUE
TO TACKLE THIS THIS DAUNTING
ISSUE PLASTIC POLLUTION IN OUR
OCEANS --
AND FINALLY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA DEFENSE IT I'M ALSO
VERY MUCH LOOKING FORWARD TO A
TWO YEAR ENGGEMENT --
ON ON THE BY DIVERSITY
INITIATIVE AND ALL THESE ISSUES
ARE INTER RELATED FOR THE
SECRETARY'S NOMINATION AND AND
THANK YOU ALL FOR YOUR TIME
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
MADAM CHAIR AND SAT SENATORS
LOOK AT FACTS ON BEHALF THE
NATURE CONSERVANCY OF PROUD TO
STAND HERE IN SUPPORT OF THE
SECRETARIES THAT NOMINATION
CONFIRMATION.
OUT JUST A COUPLE QUICK THINGS
WE REALLY THINK I THINK YOU KNOW
HIS BASS EXPERIENCES ARE REALLY.
AT BOTH THE LOCAL LEVEL AND ALSO
THE FEDERAL OF ARE VERY
IMPORTANT BUT ALSO I THINK IT
REALLY WILL YOU THINK IT'LL HELP
SURE ABSOLUTELY WE THINK HIS
EXPERIENCE AT THE LOCAL LEVEL
AND LOCAL GOVERNMENT AS WELL AS
AT THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT WILL
BE VERY.
BENEFICIAL TO HIS ROLE NOW
YOU'RE IN THE STATE AT THE STATE
LEVEL ADDITIONALLY WE REALLY
APPRECIATE THE WORK --
ALREADY IN HIS ROLLING UP HIS
SLEEVES AS SOON AS HE WAS.
APPOINTED BY THE GOVERNOR --
IN THE VOLUNTARY SETTLEMENT
AGREEMENTS --
AND BRING ALL THE STAKEHOLDERS
TOGETHER AT INDUSTRY AT AND NGOS
AND OTHERS AT ALL STATE AGENCIES
SO WE REALLY APPRECIATE THAT AND
WE ARE CERTAINLY SUPPORTIVE OF
HIS NOMINATION THANKS FOR MUCH.
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON SENATORS MY NAME
IS CATHERINE PORTER TODAY I
REPRESENT CALIFORNIA HEALTHY
NAIL SALON COLLABORATIVE.
AND ASIAN HEALTH SERVICES THE
HELPING ELSE LONG COLLABORATIVE
IS A COALITION OF ABOUT SEVENTY
ORGANIZATIONS AN INDIVIDUAL NAIL
SALON COMMUNITY MEMBERS.
ARE WE WORK TOGETHER TO IMPROVE
THE HEALTH SAFETY AND RIGHTS OF
THE LOW WAGE YOUR LOW WAGE PROP
PREDOMINANTLY WORKING WOMEN --
THAT WORK IN NAIL SALONS --
WE ENTHUSIASTICALLY AND
VIGOROUSLY SUPPORT --
MR BLUMENFELD APPOINT --
TERRY WE WORKED WITH HIM OVER
THE YEARS AND SAN FRANCISCO
DEPARTMENT OF ENVIRONMENT.
REGION NINE OF THE U. S. EPA AND
ABOUT ALWAYS BEEN IMPRESSED WITH
HIS ENTHUSIASM. TO IMPROVE AND
HIS COMMITMENT TO IMPROVING THE
WORKING LIVES OF LOW WAGE WOMEN
WORKERS --
WHEN IT COMES TO ISSUES IN THE
ENVIRONMENT TOXIC CHEMICALS IN
THE ENVIRONMENT OR OTHER ISSUES
THAT?
THE EPA COULD IMPACT SO AGAIN WE
AND THROUGH THE OPTICALLY
SUPPORT HIS --
NOMINATION AN APPOINTMENT THANK
YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
AFTERNOON CHAIR COMMITTEE
MEMBERS MY NAME SEAN BOTHWELL ON
BEHALF OF THE COMPANY BECAUSE
KEEP ALLIANCE IN THE CALIFORNIA
WATER KEEPERS.
I'M HERE TODAY IN A REALLY
STRONG SUPPORT MR BLUMENFELD FOR
HIS APPOINTMENT --
I'VE HAD THE PLEASURE OF THE
LAST COUPLE YEARS OF BEING ABLE
TO WORK CLOSELY WITH MR
BLUMENFELD ON ON VARIOUS ISSUES --
RELATED TO WATER --
AND INSTITUTIONAL THINGS AT THE
EPA AND I I I CAN SAY HE'S
EXTREMELY OUR SOLUTIONS ORIENTED --
AND REALLY ACTIONS BASIS HERE TO
ACTUALLY GET SOME WORK DONE AND
WORK COLLABORATIVELY WITH BOTH
SIDES AND I I THINK THAT'S WHY
YOU SEE SO MUCH.
STRONG SUPPORT HERE TODAY I
THINK HE CARES DEEPLY ABOUT DIED --
DIVERSITY ON INTERSTATE AGENCIES
HE CARES DEEPLY ABOUT THE
ENFORCEMENT OF OUR EXISTING LAWS
AND GETTING THE IMPLEMENTATION
OF THE ASSEMBLY SUPPORT HIS
APPOINTMENT THANK YOU
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
AFTERNOON SENATORS MY NAME'S
MIKE CLAIBORNE I'M AN ATTORNEY
WITH LEADERSHIP COUNCIL FOR
JUSTICE AND ACCOUNTABILITY AND
ALSO HERE ON BEHALF OF COMMUNITY
WATER CENTER IN CLEAN WATER
ACTION -- TO
VOICE STRONG SUPPORT FOR
CONFIRMATION OF MISTER
BLUMENTHAL THANKS [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
MA'AM SHERMAN A MEMBERS MARK
VERY WITH THE ENVIRONMENTAL
GROUP CALIFORNIANS AGAINST WASTE.
I'M NOT NEARLY AS ENTHUSIASTIC
ABOUT JARED AS EVERYONE ELSE.
A LOT TO PROVE AND I HOPE HE
WILL WORK REALLY HARD IN THIS
POSITION [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
WELL IF THAT'S THE WORST --
YOU GET [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON PRISCILLA KIDDOS
WITH CHARTER AND THREE ON BEHALF
OF ADVANCE ENERGY ECONOMY AND
STOP WASTE IN STRONG SUPPORT WE
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH YOU.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON LEASE AT VAN
FLEET BREAST CANCER PREVENTION
PARTNERS WERE A NATIONAL
ORGANIZATION THAT WORK ON
ELIMINATING THE CHEMICALS THAT
ARE BEING LINKED TO BREAST
CANCER.
WE'VE WORKED WITH CHART
BLUMENFELD IN SAN FRANCISCO
DEPARTMENT OF IN PART
ENVIRONMENT.
WATCHED HIS WORK AT THE EPA WERE
VERY ENTHUSIASTIC ABOUT HIS
NOMINATION ENCOURAGE YOU TO
CONFIRM HIS APPOINTMENT THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU.
HELLO GOOD AFTERNOON --
KILLER ROBINSON FROM
ENVIRONMENTAL AND ENERGY
CONSULTING HERE ON BEHALF OF CAL
START EVERYTHING WASTE YOUR IN
OUR ENVIRONMENTAL AND OCEAN
CONSERVANCY ALSO IN HUGE SUPPORT
OF TERRIBLE INVOLVES APPOINTMENT.
THANK YOU.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MARKUP PRIOR I'M HERE
ON BEHALF OF CHARGE POINT.
A LEADING PROVIDER OF EVEY --
INFRASTRUCTURE AND WE ARE
ENTHUSIASTICALLY SUPPORTER HIS
CONFIRMATION THANK YOU
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS MIGUEL
HERNANDEZ FROM COMING TO SEE
BECAUSE I YOU FROM THE PER
COUNTY.
HERE IN STRONG SUPPORT FOR THE
APPOINTMENT OF GERMAN LIMóN
FILLED.
OUT WE ARE HIGHLY ENCOURAGED TO
HAVE THEM --
AT THE STATE LEVEL OF WAR WITH
HIM BEFORE --
USEPA AND I KNOW THIS IS NEEDS A
STRONG LEADER STRONG SUPPORT --
IN AS LONG AS IT'S OVER FOR
CERTAIN THE NOW THAT I WAS A
BILL IF YOU'LL BE ABLE TO THE
LIVER.
AND ONCE YOU THE LIVER IS --
OUR COMMUNITY.
COUNTY IN THIS CASE IS THERE TO
SUPPORT YOU IS THERE TO ASSIST
YOU WITH ANYTHING AND AGAIN
WORDS STRONG SUPPORT FOR HIS
APPOINTMENT THANK YOU
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
WHEN THE READ A BUNCH OF
REPRESENTING AQUA CESSATION
CALIFORNIA WATER AGENCIES WERE
DELIGHTED --
AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
WITH YOU THIS YEAR. ONE OF THE
MEAT ON A WITH AUTUMN ON
CALIFORNIA WERE.
EXTREMELY YOU DELIGHTED TO HAVE
HIM BE NOMINATED THE SECRETARY
NOMINATED.
FOR THIS POSITION.
ESPECIALLY BECAUSE HE BRINGS.
THE PASSION OF WHAT IT MEANS.
TO DO THE THINGS AND SEE THE
THINGS THAT YOU ARE.
DOING. TO PROTECT THE
ENVIRONMENT SO --
THAT'S ONE THING THAT WE
CERTAINLY LOVE --
ABOUT.
HIS NOMINATION BEYOND THE
THOUGHTFULNESS AND THE
EXPERIENCE THAT HE HAS HE
ACTUALLY WANTS TO PUT THINGS
INTO AND SEE THINGS THAT.
WE ALL WANT TO PROTECT THANK YOU
VERY MUCH WELL THAT WAS
CERTAINLY A BROAD COALITION OF
SUPPORT --
ANYONE IN OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU.
I I WOULD SAY I'D AGAIN WHAT A
BROAD COALITION THE ONE SORT OF
SEMI SUPPORT GOING TO KEEP AN
EYE ON YOU COMMENT --
I THINK IS REALLY INDICATIVE OF
THE CHALLENGE WE HAVE AS IT
RELATES TO A HUGE ISSUE THAT WE
ALL KNOW IS A CHALLENGE WHICH IS
OUR RECYCLING.
A ISSUES AND PROGRAM AND I DO
THINK THAT YOU OBVIOUSLY HAVE.
THE SUPPORT OF A BROAD GROUP OF
FOLKS WHO UNDERSTAND THE NATURE
OF ALL OF THE ISSUES.
I YOUR SUCCESS IS OUR SUCCESS
AND I KNOW YOU HAVE A LOT OF
FOLKS ARE.
WITH YOU.
BECAUSE THIS IS ALL ABOUT OUR
STATE SO.
SENATOR THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
THE OUR MOTION --
MA'AM SECRETARY WILL YOU CALL
THE ROLL FOR US.
SENATORS BATES HI MONNING AYE
ROTH.
ROSS I WILL HI WILK I HI.
CONGRATULATIONS UNANIMOUS
SUPPORT.
WE WILL TAKE ABOUT A FIVE TO
SEVEN MINUTE BREAK --
AND RECONVENE FOR THE NEXT
APPOINTEE
I IS I WANT TO THANK MY
SECRETARY FOR KEEPING ME ON
TRACK I AM REMINDED ME THAT I
NEED TO LIFT THE CALL ON THE
CONSENT ITEMS.
SO THAT WE CAN.
FINISH THE VOTE MADAM SECRETARY.
ITEMS TWO THROUGH EIGHT SENATOR
ROBB.
ROB FIVE FIVE THANK YOU THAT WAS
FIVE ZERO ON OUR CONSENT
CALENDAR I APPRECIATED.
WITH THAT LET ME WELCOME MISS
JULIE SU UP TO THE DYESS.
AS THE APPOINTEE FOR SECRETARY
OF LABOR AND WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT AGENCY --
IT'S GOOD TO SEE YOU AGAIN --
LET ME ASK IF YOU WANT TO MAKE
SOME OPENING COMMENTS
ACKNOWLEDGE THE PEOPLE THAT-MIGHT BE WITH YOU I WILL NOTE
THAT THE ROOM ATTENDANTS IS
STILL AS MUCH AS IT WAS THE LAST
TIME SO OBVIOUSLY.
THESE ARE CRITICALLY IMPORTANT
APPOINTMENTS --
I WILL TURN IT OVER TO YOU
MISTER THANK YOU SO MUCH MAN
APPROACHED HIM AND SHARE ATKINS.
GOOD MORNING MEMBERS OF THE REAL
GOOD AFTERNOON COULD.
AFTERNOON MEMBERS OF THE RULES
COMMITTEE I AM HONORED TO APPEAR
BEFORE YOU TODAY AND I'M
GRATEFUL FOR THE TIME THAT YOU
SPENT MEETING WITH ME PRIOR TO
THIS HEARING.
I APPRECIATE THE CHANCE TO SHOW
MY VISION AND ENJOYED OR
CONVERSATIONS ABOUT THE LABOR
AGENCY.
I AM THE DAUGHTER OF IMMIGRANTS.
MY MOM WHO BRAVED A THIRTY DAY
VOYAGE ON A CARGO SHIP TO COME
HERE FROM CHINA BECAUSE SHE
COULDN'T AFFORD A PASSENGER
TICKET.
CAME TO AMERICA OF OPPORTUNITY
AND THEN SETTLED WITH MY DAD IN
THE STATE SYNONYMOUS WITH DREAMS.
SHE AND MY DAD FLEW UP FROM
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA TO BE HERE
TODAY.
WHILE I WAS GROWING UP MY FAMILY
OWNED A LAUNDROMAT AND DRY
CLEANING BUSINESS AND LATER AN
ICE CREAM SHOP.
I KNOW THE STRUGGLES OF SMALL
BUSINESS OWNERS WHO ARE THE
ENGINES OF OUR ECONOMY AND THE
VITAL ROLE THAT THE STATE CAN
PLAY IN HELPING THEM TO THRIVE.
FOR THE PAST EIGHT YEARS I SERVE
THE PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA AS
LABOR COMMISSIONER.
I WORKED WITH AN INCREDIBLE TEAM
OF DEDICATED PUBLIC SERVANTS. TO
COMBAT WAGE THEFT AND TO PROMOTE
ECONOMIC JUSTICE THROUGH ROBUST
ENFORCEMENT OF LABOR LAWS
[inaudible]
I I KNOW THAT ARE SEE I SAW
DURING THAT TIME THAT.
WITH A CLEAR VISION.
BOLD IDEAS AND A REAL COMMITMENT
TO MAKING GOVERNMENT WORK THAT
WE CAN TRANSFORM WHAT WE DO AND
HOW WE DO IT.
AS LABOR SECRETARY I WILL MAKE
SURE THAT EVERYBODY ON MY TEAM
REJECTS THE IDEA THAT WE HAVE TO
DO THINGS THIS WAY BECAUSE WE'VE
ALWAYS DONE THEM THIS WAY.
ALSO AS LABOR COMMISSIONER I SAW
THAT BY ENCOURAGING CREATIVITY.
TEAMWORK AND BY NEVER ASKING MY
STAFF TO WORK HARDER THAN I WAS
WILLING TO WORK.
WE MADE A TREMENDOUS IMPACT EVEN
WITH LIMITED RESOURCES.
AS LABOR SECRETARY THIS MEANS
THAT I WILL MAKE SURE WE ARE
DOING EVERYTHING WE CAN WITH THE
RESOURCES THAT WE HAVE BEFORE
ASKING FOR MORE MONEY OR MORE
STAFF.
AND I SAW THAT FOR THE LOWEST
PAID WORKERS IN OUR STATE.
WHO OFTEN WORK CRUSHING HOURS?
UNDER BRUTAL CONDITIONS.
THAT WE CAN DO BETTER BY THEM.
WHEN WE TREAT THEM WITH RESPECT
AND DIGNITY THAT THEY DESERVE WE
CAN NOT ONLY SUCCEED IN PUTTING
EARNED WAGES INTO THEIR POCKETS?
BUT WE CAN BUILD THEIR FAITH IN
THE VERY IDEA OF GOVERNMENT
ITSELF.
MY TWO DAUGHTERS ARE ALSO HERE
TODAY.
LI MEI IS A FIRST YEAR AT YALE
AND HAS PLAYED MARY POPPINS ON
STAGE.
AND I'M LIVING IS A HIGH SCHOOL
SOPHOMORE WHO ALSO PARTICIPATES
IN MUSICAL THEATER BUT WHOSE
FIRST LOVE IS COMPETITIVE CLUB
BASKETBALL.
THEY AND I ARE PRODUCTS OF THE
CALIFORNIA DREAM.
I THINK OF THE NEW SOME FOR THE
CHANCE TO WORK WITH HIM TO
PRESERVE AND EXPAND THAT DREAM.
AND I LOOK FORWARD TO MY
PARTNERSHIP WITH ALL OF YOU IN
THE YEARS AHEAD.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I'M GONNA.
SWING OVER HERE TO MY RIGHT AND
ASK SENATOR ROTH IF YOU WOULD
LIKE TO START US OFF THIS TIME
THANK YOU MAYOR PRO TEM --
CONGRATULATIONS.
TO EXCEPTIONALLY WELL QUALIFIED
FOR THIS JOB IS YOU KNOW IN MY
PAST LIFE I WAS A CUSTOMER OF
THE AGENCIES THE ONE THAT YOU.
HEADED UP BEFORE IN THE AGENCIES
THAT YOU NOW WILL SUPERVISE.
THE SECRETARY AND I LOOK FORWARD
TO WATCHING.
HOW YOU WORK AND HOW YOU DEVELOP
AND?
HOW YOU ACCOMPLISH THE
PRIORITIES THAT YOUR PRIORITIES
THAT WE HAD THE PLEASURE TO
DISCUSS DURING OUR OFFICE
MEETING [inaudible]
I I'M ALSO LOOKING FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH YOU TO AS WE
INDICATED I INDICATED TO YOU
DURING OUR MEETING.
SECURING A REGULAR IN CONSTANT
CONSISTENT FUNDING FOR OUR
VETERANS EMPLOYMENT PLACEMENT
PROGRAMS INCLUDING OUR STATES
WORK FOR WARRIORS PROGRAM.
WORKING.
TO UTILIZE THE WHAT APPEARED TO
BE ACCUMULATED PAGA FUNDS.
OF TO EXPAND EMPLOYER OUT REACH
BECAUSE DURING MY TIME AS A
IMPLEMENT PRACTITIONER AND
LAWYER IN THE STATE NOW FORTY
FIVE YEARS.
OF IT.
I FIND IT TO SMALL EMPLOYERS
HAVE A VERY VERY DIFFICULT TIME.
UNDERSTANDING WHAT THEY'RE
REQUIRED TO DO THE LAWS THAT WE
PASS THE REGULATIONS THAT THE
AGENCIES IMPOSE.
AND I THINK IT MIGHT BE A GOOD
USE OF SOME OF THAT PAGANINI TO
EXPLAIN EXPAND AND EMPLOYER OUT
REACH IN THE STATE AND I KNOW.
THAT YOU SHARE THAT VIEW AND
THAT YOU INTEND TO STEP OUT.
ON THAT AS WELL [inaudible]
AND FINALLY.
TAKING A LOOK AT HOW WE HAVE
CONNECTED OUR CAREER TECH
EDUCATION PROGRAMS IN THIS.
STATE FROM THE EDUCATION CONSORT
CONTROL SURE THAT WERE SET UP A
COUPLE YEARS AGO.
AND PERHAPS EULOGIZING THE
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT BOARD'S OR
SOME SIMILAR ENTITY TO COLLECT
AND COMPILE AN INVENTORY OF JOB
SKILL NEEDS AND AND POSITION
NEEDS IN THE STATE.
AND BETTER CONNECT THE DEMAND
SIDE WITH THE EDUCATIONAL
COMPONENT.
OF C. T. E..
I KNOW THE YOU SHARE THOSE
PRIORITIES AND I LOOK FORWARD TO
SEEING WHAT YOU'RE ABLE TO
ACCOMPLISH WHEN.
YOU ARE CERTAINLY CONFIRMED
FORWARD TO MAKING THAT MOTION TO
CONFIRM THAT NOMINATION AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME CONGRATULATIONS.
HOW MUCH SENATOR?
MISTER VICE CHAIRMAN.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR.
I'M IN PRESSURE NO LONGER --
CHAIR OF BUDGETS OF FOUR YOU'RE
STILL ADVOCATING.
THAT'S GREAT.
THOROUGHLY ENJOYED OUR
CONVERSATION I'M I'M GONNA SHOOT
A QUESTION THAT I ASKED YOU TO
PRIVATELY JUST BECAUSE I THOUGHT
WAS REALLY INTERESTING IN IN
TERMS OF PAGA.
AND WHAT ARE YOUR PLANS TO TRY
TO ADDRESS THAT SO.
IF YOU COULD DO THAT I WOULD
REALLY APPRECIATE IT SO THE
PRIVATE ATTORNEY GENERAL'S ACTOR
PAGA WAS A STATE LAW PASSED IN
RECOGNITION OF THE FACT THAT
GOVERNMENT DIDN'T HAVE ALL THE
RESOURCES TO ENFORCE ALL OF THE
LABOR LAWS.
AND SO THE IDEA WAS THAT IT GAVE
INDIVIDUALS A CHANCE TO GO TO
COURT TO COLLECT STATE PENALTIES.
AND THEN 75% OF WHAT THEY
COLLECTED WILL GO TO THE STATE
AND 25% WOULD GO TO THE
PLAINTIFF WHO BROUGHT THE SUIT.
A FEW YEARS AGO THE LEGISLATURE
PASSED.
A LAW TO HELP THE LABOR AGENCY
TO BETTER DOCUMENT HOW PULGAS
WORKING WHAT ABUSES THERE ARE
AND WHAT WE SHOULD BE DOING TO
CURB THEM.
SO OVER THE LAST COUPLE YEARS
AFTER THE LABOR AGENCY HAS BEEN
DOING WE NOW --
GET ONLINE NOTICES FROM EVERY
PLAINTIFF WHO WANTS TO FALL UPON
THE SUIT WERE SUPPOSED TO GET
ALL OF THEM WE ARE STILL WORKING
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE ACTUALLY OF
THAT THIS FULL UTILIZATION OF
THE SYSTEM.
BUT THEN WE HAVE A CHANCE TO
LOOK AT THE WHETHER WE WILL TAKE
ANY OF THEM FOR INVESTIGATION.
WE HAVE DONE THAT ALTHOUGH AS I
WAS UP FRANK IN OUR CONVERSATION
IS STILL A VERY SMALL PERCENTAGE
OF THE NOTICES THAT WE ACTUALLY
TAKE INSIDE TO INVESTIGATE --
AND THEN AFTER THAT NOTICE THE
PLATE TO FILE SUIT AND WHAT
WE'RE DOING IS WE'RE TRACKING OF
THE OUTCOMES OF THOSE CASES WE
NOW GET SETTLEMENTS BEFORE THEY
ARE FINALIZED SO WE HAVE A
CHANCE TO LOOK AND SEE.
ARE ALL THE ISSUES THAT WERE
ALLEGE ACTUALLY --
BEING RESOLVED OUR IS THE STATE
GETTING THE PENALTIES THAT WE
SHOULD BE GETTING AND ARE THESE
CASES FOR THE PURPOSES OF THE PA
THE STATUTE WHICH IS TO MAKE
SURE THAT LABOR LAWS ARE BEING
ENFORCED.
WHEN THE GOVERNMENT IS UNABLE TO
STEP IT?
UP AND WE'RE ALSO REALLYLOOKING
AT TRACKING TRENDS AND ABUSE
THAT'S GOING ON SO WE'RE LOOKING
TO SEE WHETHER THERE ARE OF
CERTAIN PARTY CERTAIN ATTORNEYS
WHO ARE.
CONSTANTLY FILING THE SUIT TO
WEAR THOSE OUTCOMES ARE NOT
CONSISTENT WITH UP WITH PAGA --
PURPOSES AND SO WE'RE TAKING A
CLOSE LOOK AT THAT WILL CONTINUE
TO DO THAT AND I I WE HAD A
REALLY REALLY GREAT CONVERSATION
ABOUT THE CONCERNS THAT EXIST AS
I DID WAS SENATOR BATES.
AND SO --
WE'RE VERY HOPEFUL THAT THROUGH
THE INFORMATION GATHERING AND
ACCOUNTABILITY AND WORKING WITH
PARTIES IN THE STATE TO GIVE US
FULL INFORMATION THAT WE WILL
BOTH --
PROMOTE THE RIGHT PURPOSE THE
PAGA AND CURB THE THE OVER THE
TO JUSTICE THAT --
IS A PROBLEM ESPECIALLY FOR
SMALL BUSINESSES FOR DEVOTING
EYEING CONGRATULATIONS THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
Q. SENATOR BAIT.
WELL CONGRATULATIONS MISS SUE
AND AM THANK YOU --
FOR THAT I THINK VERY
ILLUMINATING TIME THAT WE HAD TO
YOU KNOW CONVERSATIONS ABOUT
SOME OF THESE.
I CONSIDER THEM VERY VEXING
PROBLEMS BECAUSE WE WANNA
CERTAINLY PER TAPPED ON YOU KNOW
OUR ON THE PLAYERS OUT THERE BUT
IT WAS IMPORTANT LEAN ENSURE
THAT THERE ARE NOT ABUSES SOB
FOR EMPLOYEES AND THAT'S THAT'S
A DIFFICULT THING TO NAVIGATE ON
CERTAINLY AND SIGNED PLEASED TO
HEAR THAT --
YOU'RE GATHERING THE DATA THAT I
THINK WILL BE VERY IMPORTANT IN
TERMS OF FUTURE LEGISLATION THAT
MIGHT CORRECT --
ABUSE AND I THINK WE TALK TO
SOMEONE ABOUT GIVING SOME
OPPORTUNITY FOR CARRYING A ON AN
ABUSE --
THAT WAS NOT INTENDED THAT WOULD
CERTAINLY HELP AND I CAN GIVE
CONFIDENCE FUND THAT'S WHAT
WE'RE TRYING TO DO HERE.
SURE THERE ARE PEOPLE OUT THERE
HAVE A GREAT CONFIDENCE IN THEIR
GOVERNMENT IN TERMS OF THE WAY
THEY REGULATE.
IN TERMS OF THE WAY THEY ARE
SOLVE PROBLEMS THAT ONE THAT IS
GOING TO BE ON A HUGE AND
CONTINUES TO BE HUGE AND WE
SPOKE I THINK IT'S REAL
IMPORTANT.
THE THE MOST ON I THINK
THREATENING THING ABOUT DYNAMAX
AT THIS POINT IS THIS
RETROACTIVE PROVISION OF
POTENTIAL.
IN I'D LIKE TO KNOW ON YOU KNOW
IT CAN BE VERY CATASTROPHIC ON
SOME BUSINESS IN PARTICULAR
SMALLER BUSINESSES.
OUT WOULD YOU BE SUPPORTIVE OF
ANY REFORM THAT GOES IN THE
DIRECTION OF DEALING WITH THE
RETROACTIVITY AND SOMEHOW BOB.
YOU KNOW SITTING A TIME LINE
SOMETHING THAT WOULD BE HELPFUL.
I IN TERMS OF THIS APPLICATION
IF THERE'S NOT A MAJOR REFORM OR
WEEK I KNOW THERE'S LEGISLATION
OUT THERE LOOKING OUT.
REPEALING AT AND GOING BACK TO
MORE DOWN LOWER CODIFYING THAT
MAKE THIS RETROACTIVITY THING IS
WHEN I CONTINUE TO HEAR FROM THE
FOLKS THAT COME.
TO MY OFFICER THAT I NEED IN
THAT AND IN THE DISTRICT OF SO
I'M GOING FORWARD YOU GOT A NEW
LAW WE GOT TO FOLLOW THAT.
ARE MAJOR CHANGE FROM WHAT USED
TO BE HOW ARE WE GOING TO BE
PROTECTED SO COULD YOU EXPAND ON
MATTER.
AT LEAST GIVE US SOME PATHWAY
THAT WE MIGHT ALL CONSIDER ****
WE TRY TO DO WHAT I JUST SAID
BALLOTS [inaudible]
AXEL.
THE ISSUES OF MISS
CLASSIFICATION THAT WERE DRESSED
IN DYNAMICS OF CERTAINLY DID NOT --
BEGIN WITH DYNAMAX AND IS A LOT
ALL BY DYNAMIX BUT IN THAT
UNANIMOUS SUPREME COURT DECISION
THE COURT BASICALLY RECOGNIZE
THAT MISS CLASSIFICATION.
IS A SERIOUS THREAT TO BOTH
EMPLOYEES AND THOSE WHO SHOULD
ENJOY THE PROTECTIONS OF OUR
LABOR LAWS AS EMPLOYEES.
AS WELL AS TO BUSINESSES WHO
SHOULD NOT BE FORCED INTO A RACE
TO THE BOTTOM RIGHT --
WHEN IT COMES TO OF THE THE
COSTS AND THE RESPONSIBILITIES
OF RUNNING A BUSINESS?
AND THAT DECISION ADOPTED A MORE
SIMPLIFIED A. B. C. TEST FOR
DETERMINE WHETHER SOMEBODY IS AN
EMPLOYEE OR INDEPENDENT
CONTRACTOR.
AND WHAT IT DID WAS BUILT ON
SOME EXISTING CASE LAW ABOUT ONE
OF THE THREE DEFINITIONS IN THE
WAGE ORDERS TO SUFFER PERMIT
STANDARD.
AND SO WE IN THIS ADMINISTRATION
ALSO RECOGNIZE THAT THIS IS A
QUESTION THAT'S BIGGER THAN
DYNAMAX THAT IS ABOUT WHAT IS
THE UP FOR A PROMISE THAT OF THE
THAT WE WANT TO MAKE TO
EMPLOYEES AT THE CALIFORNIA TO
PEOPLE WORKING CALIFORNIA.
WHERE THE STANDARDS THAT WE WANT
TO EXIST REGARDLESS OF STATUS
AND HOW DO WE PRESERVE THE
ABILITY FOR BUSINESSES TO BE
INNOVATIVE AND FLEXIBLE AND TWO
ADOPTED CHANGES IN THE ECONOMY?
AND THOSE OF THE BALANCES THAT
WE ARE ALL TRYING TO STRIKE IT'S
A CHALLENGE.
THAT I THINK WILL BE ONE THE
MOST IMPORTANT THINGS WE DEAL
WITH.
IN CONJUNCTION WITH YOU THE
LEGISLATURE IN THIS
ADMINISTRATION AND WE HAVE HAD A
AN OPEN DOOR POLICY ABOUT THIS
I'VE MET WITH --
FOLKS ON ALL SIDES OF THE ISSUE
RIGHT EMPLOYEES --
AND UNIONS WHO ARE DEDICATED TO
PRESERVING THE PROTECTIONS THAT
HAVE BEEN SO HARD --
EMPLOYERS AND THOSE IN THE
INDUSTRY MOST DIRECTLY AFFECTED
BY THE DYNAMIC DECISION WHO --
FRANKLY WANT FLEXIBILITY AND
ALSO RECOGNIZE THAT THEY WANT A
LEVEL PLAYING FIELD.
AND SO WILL CONTINUE THOSE
CONVERSATIONS AS YOU MENTIONED
CENTER THERE IS LEGISLATION
ALREADY IN THE WORKS AND I WILL
BE DEDICATED TO ENFORCING
WHATEVER --
IS IS PASSED I WILL SAY ON THE
RETROACTIVITY ISSUE --
I THINK THAT.
FOLLOWING THE CASE THERE WAS A
REQUEST TO THE COURT. TO FIND
THAT THE DECISION SHOULD BE
PROSPECTIVE ONLY AND THE COURT
OF DID REFUSE TO TAKE THAT STEP --
AND SO AT THIS POINT WE'RE JUST
LOOKING AT ALL THE ISSUES THAT
WE TALKED ABOUT AND TRY TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE DO WHAT IS BOTH
FAIR AND JUST AND ALSO
CONSISTENT WITH WHAT WITH WHAT
THE COURT DETERMINED AND WE'RE
STILL LOOKING ALL THOSE ISSUES.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR RESPONSE AND
CERTAINLY I THINK YOUR
COMMITMENT TO DIG A LITTLE
DEEPER INTO IT AND AND CERTAINLY
AND SHE MORE OR TRY TO ACHIEVE
THE ON THE BALLOT SO I KNOW THAT
YOU ARE WELL.
NOTED FOR YOUR ABILITY TO SEE
COMPROMISE AND HE IN THE
SOLUTION OT.
SO WE WE SHOULD THE BILL CLOSELY
AND CONGRATULATIONS AGAIN
[inaudible]
SENATOR MINING.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
WELCOME IS TO OWN AND OFFER MY
CONGRATULATIONS AS WELL ON YEAR
APPOINTMENT BY THE GOVERNOR.
AND ALSO WELCOME YOUR PARENTS
AND YOUR DAUGHTER'S I'M SURE
THEY'RE VERY PROUD TO BE HERE
ODAY IS I KNOW YEAR EQUALLY
PROUD OF THEM --
YOU HAVE AN AMAZING BACKGROUND
IN.
IS A CAL BEAR I EVEN HAVE TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT YOU GOT A GOOD
FOUNDATION AT STANFORD IT LOOKS
LIKE -- FOR
AN AMAZING CAREER YOUR EIGHT
YEARS -- AS
LABOR COMMISSIONER --
CERTAINLY GIVES YOU AN AMAZING.
UNDERSTANDING OF OUR STATE IN.
THE FORCES OF BUSINESS AT ALL
DIFFERENT LEVELS AND WORKERS
UNIONIZED IN.
NON UNIONIZED IT CETERA.
ON I KNOW YOU PRESIDED AS LABOR
COMMISSIONER WITH THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE
REQUIREMENT FOR FARM LABOR
CONTRACTORS TO PROVIDE SEXUAL
HARASSMENT PREVENTION TRAINING.
SO IF YOU COULD PROVIDE THE
COMMITTEE A BRIEF UPDATE ON YOUR
VIEWS ON THE IMPLEMENTATION OF
THAT PROTECTION FOR FARMWORKERS.
HAPPY TO DO THAT SO THANK YOU TO
THE SENATOR FOR THAT LEGISLATION --
THE IT WAS A REQUIREMENT THAT OF
FARM LABOR CONTRACTORS --
EDUCATE NOT JUST SUPERVISORS
BROSSEAU EMPLOYEES ON HOW TO
PREVENT SEXUAL HARASSMENT --
AND THAT LAW WHEN THE LAW FIRST
WENT INTO EFFECT I SENT A NOTICE
OUT -- TO
THE AFFECTED COMMUNITY.
LABOR CONTRACTORS WHO WE HAD
REGISTERED --
WITH THE WITH THE LABOR
COMMISSIONER TO INFORM THEM OF
THE REQUIREMENTS.
AND AND WE ALSO CONTACT WITH
SOMEONE IN MY OFFICE TO BE ABLE
TO PROVIDE ASSISTANCE OR OR
CONTINUING OF CONSULTATION ON ON
SOME OF THE NEW REQUIREMENTS AND
I THINK THAT'S RELATED.
TO HOW WE HELP ON BUSINESSES TO
MAKE SURE THAT THEY ARE ABLE TO
COMPLY WITH THE WITH THE
IMPORTANT POLICIES THAT ARE PUT
FORTH UP FROM THIS BODY.
AND JUST THIS PAST WEEK WE
ISSUED OUR FOR CITATIONS FOR
EMPLOYERS FARM LABOR CONTRACTORS
WHO HAD NOT PROVIDED THAT
EDUCATION.
AND I THINK WHAT'S IMPORTANT IS
NOT ONLY THAT WE GIVE EMPLOYERS
NOTICE THAT WE GIVE THEM TIME TO
COMPLY BUT THEN ALSO THAT WILL
FORCE THE LAWS THAT THAT HAVE
BEEN WRITTEN.
AND THAT'S BOTH IMPORTANT TO THE
SPECIFIC EMPLOYEES AFFECTED BUT
ALSO TO SEND A STRONG MESSAGE
THAT WE ARE SERIOUS ABOUT THE
BASIC STANDARDS THAT WE WANT TO
EXIST IN CALIFORNIA AND WE WANT
A WORKING PEOPLE AND AND THEIR
BUSINESS.
HONEST.
COMPETING TO ENJOY SO IF YOU
CITING THE TRAINING OF FEAR TO
PROVIDE --
THE INFORMATION THAT WAS PART IN
THE TRAINING AND OUR HOPE IS
THAT THAT WILL ALSO HAVE A
RIPPLE EFFECT AND ENCOURAGE.
OTHER FLC IS WERE NOT.
ALREADY IN COMPLIANCE --
TO TO COME INTO COMPLIANCE WE
ALSO INTRODUCED A NEW FORM ON
THE LABOR COMMISSION'S WEBSITE
THAT WOULD ALLOW PEOPLE WHO KNOW
THAT THE TRAINING IS NOT TAKING
PLACE TO SPECIFICALLY LET US
KNOW ABOUT THAT SO WE REALLY TRY
TO UPGRADE OUR ABILITY.
FOR ONLINE ACCESS TO OUR
SERVICES DURING MY TIME AS LABOR
COMMISSIONER AND MAKING SURE
THAT WE HAVE FORMS THAT ARE EASY
TO UNDERSTAND AND TRANSLATED AND
EASY TO USE WAS A KEY PART OF
BECOMING MORE ACCESSIBLE AS
GOVERNMENT.
WE DO HAVE A SPECIAL FORM ALSO
FOR THAT PARTICULAR VIOLATE FREE
ONE I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR YOUR
LEADERSHIP WITH THAT AND AS YOU
MENTIONED --
ONE OF THE FEATURES OF THAT
IMPLEMENTATION IS TO GIVE FARM
LABOR CONTRACTORS THE
OPPORTUNITY TO COMPLY.
THE AGENCY'S GOAL IS TO ACHIEVE
THE TRAINING IN THE PROTECTION
OF THE WORK FORCE.
IN THAT THE PENALTY PHASES ARE
LATER AFTER.
NOT --
REFUSING TO COMPLY BASICALLY --
WE ALSO TALKED SOME ABOUT THE
UNDER WE KNOW THAT LITERALLY
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS A YEAR IS
CHANGING HANDS BUT OFTEN WITH.
WORKERS NOT BEING PAID.
WHAT THEIR DO AND OFTEN?
LAW ABIDING EMPLOYERS.
BEING PUT AT A COMPETITIVE
DISADVANTAGE BY THOSE WHO ARE
NOT PLAYING BY THE RULES --
DURING YOUR TENURE AN ISSUE MOVE
FORWARD.
WELL WHAT CAN BE DONE --
WHAT HAS BEEN DONE FOR BETTER
COORDINATION AMONG THE VARIOUS
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES IN SHARING
INFORMATION AND DATA AND?
ALSO.
PUBLICIZING WHERE YOU HAVE FOUND
VIOLATORS SO THAT OTHERS WHO
MIGHT BE TEMPTED TO CUT CORNERS
REALIZE THAT THERE WILL BE
CONSEQUENCES.
AS LABOR COMMISSIONER --
I REALLY MOVED THE AGENCY AWAY
FROM THE SWEEPING METHOD OF
ENFORCEMENT MEANING YOU'RE MORE
INSPECTIONS THE BETTER AND
RANDOM INSPECTIONS.
BUT WE REALLY MOVED TO A
TARGETED MORE STRATEGIC APPROACH
MEANING WE WERE LOOKING AT
EMPLOYERS BASED ON INFORMATION
WE GATHERED AHEAD OF TIME BASED
ON PARTNERSHIPS --
ON THE GROUND FOR THOSE WHO WERE
ALREADY BREAKING THE LAW.
AND THAT MAKES SENSE IT'S JUST
GOOD GOVERNMENT RIGHT WE DON'T
WANT TO BE INSPECTING EMPLOYERS
WERE PLAYING BY THE RULES
THERE'S NO REASON. FOR THEM TO
HAVE TO STOP THEIR BUSINESS FOR
INSPECTION IT'S NOT A GOOD USE
OF GOVERNMENT SOURCES IT DOESN'T-HELP WORKERS --
AND WE WANTED TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE WERE GOING TO THE WORST
VIOLATORS AND FINDING.
ALL OF THE WAY THE LAW MAKING
LAWBREAKING COSTLY AND THEN
TRYING TO CHANGE BEHAVIOR.
AND SO THAT WAS OUR POST
UNDERGROUND ECONOMY AND I'M
REALLY EXCITED TO EXPAND THAT
MODEL ACROSS THE LABOR AGENCY.
TO REALLY LOOK AT HOW WE CAN BE
MORE STRATEGIC AT EVERY LEVEL SO
THAT WERE USING GOVERNMENT
RESOURCE IN A SMART WAY --
SO THAT WE ARE GOING TO WEAR THE
BAD ACTORS ARE WHEN I CAME WHEN
I BECAME LABOR COMMISSIONER.
ROUGHLY HALF A LITTLE BIT LESS
THAN HALF OF ALL INSPECTIONS LED
TO A CITATION OF ANY KIND.
WHICH MEANS THAT ABOUT HALF OF
INSPECTIONS WERE NOT OF ANYBODY
THAT WAS EITHER THE LAW WAS NOT
BEING BROKEN OR THEY WERE BEGIN
DOING ENOUGH TO FIND IT.
AND IN THE LAST EIGHT YEARS WE
HAVE GREATLY IMPROVED IN THAT
AREA WE ARE BETWEEN 8090% OF THE
INSPECTIONS THAT WE DO ACTUALLY
IS ALL TODAY CITATION.
AND IN THE STRATEGIC APPROACH WE
WORK WITH COMMITTEE BASED
PARTNERS TO TALK TO WORKERS
OFFSITE BEFORE WE DO AN
INSPECTION WHERE WE LOOK DEEPLY
FOR DO WE DO COMPLEX WAIT AUDITS
TO FIND OUT WHETHER WORKERS.
IT WOULD WORK BECAUSE OF THE BIG
GUY WHICH IS HOW MUCHTHEY'RE
OWED IN THOSE CASES WE'RE AT
ABOUT A 100% RATE IN TERMS OF
OUR INSPECTION TO CITATION.
SO THAT BETTER TARGETING IS JUST
IT'S IT'S IT'S IT'S SMART AND
IT'S GOOD ENFORCEMENT IS IS WITH
WHAT HAS GAINED SUPPORT FROM
BOTH EMPLOYEES AND EMPLOYERS FOR
FOR OUR ATTACK ON THE
UNDERGROUND ECONOMY.
THANK YOU IN IN JUST A FINAL
POINT ON THAT I BELIEVE.
YOU'RE AGENCIES ALSO AVAILABLE
TO EMPLOYERS IF THEY KNOW A
COMPETITORS BREAKING THE RULES
THAT CAN ALSO GET THE ATTENTION.
OF THE AGENCY ABSOLUTELY RIGHT
Q. SENATOR MINING --
YOU KNOW ON ALONG THE STANFORD
CAL COMIN I JUST WANT TO KNOW.
IF YOU'RE ABLE TO LIKE MITIGATE
BETWEEN THE HARVARD YALE
SITUATION AT HOME.
A SERIOUS QUESTION.
THERE'S A SMILE SO I DON'T KNOW
WHAT THE ANSWER TO THAT IS --
QUICKLY A BECAUSE I THINK MY
COLLEAGUES HAVE BEEN PRETTY GOOD
TO COVER SOME PRETTY IMPORTANT
ISSUES.
AND OF COURSE --
YOUR RESPONSES AT THAT YOU
PROVIDED THE RULES COMMITTEE AND
IT'S CLEAR FROM LISTENING TO YOU
YOU'VE YOU'VE REALLY GOT A
HANDLE.
ON ALL OF THE RELEVANT ISSUES OF
THE DEPARTMENTS THAT YOU'RE
GOING TO OVERSEE.
ANY COMMENTS ON WORKERS
COMPENSATION ISSUE I I MEAN I
KNOW THIS IS.
JUST GETTING STARTED IT'S THE
ONE THING I HEAR ABOUT --
IT WHEN I'M UP AND DOWN THE
STATE TALKING TO ANY GROUP OF
BUSINESS ORGANIZATIONS YOU WE
DID A LOT OF WORK.%
I WELL THE PREVIOUS
ADMINISTRATION. TO TRY TO
ADDRESS SOME ISSUES BUT I I
STILL HERE SO I GUESS IT'S FROM
WHAT PERSPECTIVE YOU SAID.
ARE THERE ISSUES YOU THINK ARE
THAT WE NEED TO TAKE A LOOK AT
AN ADDRESS --
AND AGAIN IT DEPENDS LARGE SMALL
BUT JUST FROM THE BROAD VIEW.
SO I WILL SAY THAT FROM WHERE I
SIT AND AS YOU NOTED I'M STILL
LEARNING --
AND I'M STILL GETTING FAMILIAR
WITH ALL ASPECTS OF THE JOB.
BUT THE LEGISLATION THAT WAS
PASSED A FEW YEARS AGO HAS
RESULTED IN IMPROVEMENTS SO I
WOULD SAY WE'RE ON THE RIGHT
TRACK WHEN IT COMES --
TO WORKERS COMP REFORM AND
MAKING SURE THAT THE MAIN
PRIORITIES OF OUR WORKERS COMP
SYSTEM WHICH IS TO INSURE THE
INJURED WORKERS GET THE
TREATMENT THAT THEY NEED TO GET
BACK TO WORK AS QUICKLY AS THEY
CAN.
AND THAT WE CONTROL COSTS FOR
EMPLOYERS THAT THOSE TWO GOALS.
ARE BEING MET THEHAVE
IMPROVEMENTS IN THAT AREA DUE TO
THE CHANGES LEGISLATIVE CHANGES
THAT WERE PASSED A FEW YEARS AGO --
WITH THINGS LIKE INDEPENDENT
MEDICAL REVIEW WE'VE CUT DOWN
THE TIME TO RESOLVE MEDICAL
DISPUTES DRAMATICALLY --
FROM WHAT WAS NINE TO TWELVE
MONTHS AND NOW IT'S LIKE THIRTY
TO FORTY FIVE DAYS.
AND SO THOSE ARE IMPROVEMENTS IN
THE SYSTEM WE ARE ALSO UPGRADING
OUR OUR DATABASE ARE SO THROUGH
THAT.
I AM VERY DATA DRIVEN ABOUT HOW
WE SHOULD DO OUR WORK SO I WILL
BE LOOKING CLOSELY WITH MY
DEPARTMENT OF MY DIVISIONS AT
WHAT THE DATA TELLS US.
WHAT WE'RE LEARNING ABOUT ANY
ONGOING ABUSES PROBLEMS FRICTION
IN THE SYSTEM THINGS WE NEED TO
IMPROVE AND --
CERTAINLY TRYING TO ADDRESS ALL
OF THOSE TO THE BEST OF MY
ABILITY.
WELL THANK YOU I WILL BE
INTERESTED AS YOU GET UNDER WAY
IN THIS NEW --
POSITION.
AS YOU TRAVEL THE STATE
CERTAINLY I HAVE HEARD FROM --
SILICON VALLEY ORANGE COUNTY OF
MY OWN COMMUNITY IN SAN DIEGO
STARTING FROM THE TIME WHEN I
WAS SPEAKER AND STARTED TO DO
THOSE.
CONVERSATIONS THAT WHILE THERE
HAVE BEEN MAJOR IMPROVEMENTS AND
I TRIED TO FOCUS IN ON THE
SPECIFICS WHEN PEOPLE WOULD MAKE
COMMENTS.
AND IT SEEMS TO BE THE MID TO
SMALL SIZE BUSINESSES HAVE
COMMENTS NOW I KNOW WE CANNOT
PLEASE EVERYONE IN THAT
BALANCING ACT OF OF HOW YOU
ADDRESSES ISSUES BUT I'D BE
INTERESTED IN OUR AFTER A PERIOD
OF TIME TO COME BACK TO YOU AND
ASK YOU WHAT YOUR THOUGHTS.
ARE ON THAT.
AND THEN AS WE YOU KNOW I'M
GONNA KNOCK ON WOOD EVERYONE
KEEPS PREDICTING A DOWNTURN IN
THE ECONOMY YOU KNOW I I AND I
KNOW IT SOME POINT THAT WILL
ALWAYS BE THE CASE.
BUT WE HAD CERTAINLY ISSUES IN
THE LAST.
NUMBER OF YEARS --
TWO THOUSAND EIGHT NINE TEN
AROUND EIGHTY D. AND AT THE WORK
FORCE ABILITY TO RESPOND.
TO OUR CITIZENS AROUND
UNEMPLOYMENT AND ACCESS TO THE
DEPARTMENT SO MUCH SO THAT I
THINK THE EMPLOYEES WERE REALLY
SUFFERING FROM MORALE BURN OUT.
ALL THOSE THINGS AND STRIKE
TEAMS HAD TO BE SENT ND BE
HELPFUL I AM.
HOPEFUL THAT ALL OF THAT IS MUCH
BETTER GRANTED YOU'RE IN THE
POSITION NEWLY MUCH BETTER BUT
MUCH LIKE OUR RAINY DAY FUND
PREPARES US FOR A A YOU KNOW IF
THERE IS A DOWNTURN --
FOR A SOFTER LANDING OF SUCH
WILL EDT HAVE THE ABILITY.
TO ARE NOT BE PUT BACK IN THE
SAME POSITION WITH THE LEVEL OF
STAFFING EMPLOYEES.
AND HAVE WE RECTIFY THAT TO THE
DEGREE THAT WE ARE WILL BE ABLE
TO APPROACH ANYTHING COMING UP.
BETTER SUITED THEM WE WERE IN
THE LAST.
SO THAT IS DEFINITELY A HIGH
PRIORITY FOR FOR FOR ME AND FOR
THIS ADMINISTRATION --
I THINK THAT THERE ARE TWO
APPROACHES THAT ONE IS THAT WE
DO NEED TO GUARD AGAINST THAT
KIND OF DOWNTURN --
WE APPRECIATE THE SUPPORT THE
LEGISLATURE UPGRADING ALSO THE
EDT SYSTEM WE THINK THAT THAT
WILL THAT WILL OBVIOUSLY HELP
AND AND AND SOFTEN THE BLOW.
I THINK THAT THE OTHER PIECE OF
THIS IS THAT THERE IS THERE ARE
TREMENDOUS OPPORTUNITIES CREATED
BY THE BY THE INVESTMENTS THAT
WILL BE MADE.
IN THE YEARS TO COME AND YOU
KNOW IN IN IN CLIMATE WHICH
WHICH WHAT WAS JUST DISCUSSED IN
HOUSING AND INFRASTRUCTURE --
AND ALL OF THESE GREAT
OPPORTUNITIES FOR GROWTH AND FOR
GOOD JOBS AND SO UNDER THE LABOR
WORKFORCE AGENCY WE ALSO HAVE
ALL THE WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
WORK WHICH IS ABOUT MAKING SURE
THAT WE ARE ALIGNING.
THE SKILLS ABILITIES IN THE
TALENTS OF CALIFORNIANS WITH THE
JOBS THAT WE HAVE AND WITH GOOD
HIGH QUALITY FAMILY SUPPORTING
JOBS.
AND SO THE MORE WE CAN DO THAT
THE MORE WE GUARD AGAINST THE
DOWNTURN ALTOGETHER BY CREATING
THE MOST ROBUST ECONOMY WE HAVE.
WHERE WE INSURE THAT A WE USED
CALIFORNIANS FOR THE WORK THAT
WE NEED AND MAKE SURE THEY'RE
TRAINED AND SKILLED AND
CONNECTED TO EMPLOYERS TO DO
THAT?
AND SO I THINK THAT'S A PART OF
THE ANSWER BUT ASSUMING THAT
THERE THAT THERE ARE GREATER
NEEDS ON UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE
SIDE I'M VERY COMMITTED TO WORK
WITH EASY TO MAKING SURE THAT WE
CAN.
PROVIDE BENEFITS IN A TIMELY AND
QUICK AND ACCURATE MANNER AND
CERTAINLY ARE.
GIVEN YOUR HISTORY SUPPORT THE
STAFF.
ABSOLUTELY THANK YOU --
SENATOR ROTH AND PRO TO MESS
ABSOLUTELY COMMON QUESTION.
MADAM SECRETARY WE'VE BEEN STE
WE SPENT A LITTLE BIT OF TIME
TODAY TALKING ABOUT ENFORCEMENT
ACTIONS WHETHER IT'S IN THE AG
INDUSTRY OR OTHERS.
AND I'M ALL FOR ENFORCEMENT
THAT'S WHAT MAKES OUR ECONOMY
RUN THAT'S WHAT KEEPS THINGS
COMPETITIVE AND KEEPS THINGS
FAIR -- BUT
AS I MENTIONED BEFORE BRIEFLY I
DO THINK AND I WOULD ASK YOU TO
TAKE A LOOK AT HOW WE
DISSEMINATE INFORMATION
REGARDING THE REQUIREMENTS OF
THE WORKPLACE IN CALIFORNIA TO
EMPLOYERS BOTH LARGE AND IN
PARTICULAR SMALL.
NEWSPAPERS ARE NOT WHAT THEY
USED TO BE IT IS THE INTERNET
AGE BUT NOT ALL OF OUR SMALL
BUSINESS.
MEN AND WOMEN OPERATORS ARE
INTERNET SAVVY OR HAVE ACCESS TO
THE INTERNET.
AND I'M NOT SURE THAT IS
SUFFICIENT ANYMORE.
TO PRINT A A NOTICE RESEARCHERS
OF NOTICES THAT WE POST ON A
BULLETIN BOARD SOMEWHERE.
AND THEN EXPECT THE EMPLOYMENT
COMMUNITY IN COR COMMUNITY TO
UNDERSTAND WITH SMALL EMPLOYERS.
WHAT THEY NEED TO DO TO COMPLY
THERE ARE PEOPLE WHO TRY TO
AVOID INVADE?
AND THE THEY SHOULD BE CAUGHT
AND THEY SHOULD BE APPROPRIATELY
PUNISHED.
AND IN SOME CASES PUT OUT OF
BUSINESS BUT WHAT I HATE TO SEE.
IS THE GOTCHA.
WHERE?
GOVERNMENT AGENCIES DON'T DO AS
MUCH AS THEY CAN TO DISSEMINATE
THE INFORMATION.
BEFORE THEY COME IN WITH THE
ENFORCEMENT TEAM.
AND SLEPT PENALTIES ON TO GREECE
SMALL BUSINESS SO.
NOT A QUESTION BUT IT'S A
REQUEST IN THE REQUEST IS THAT
YOU TAKE A LOOK AT HOW.
THE AGENCIES THAT YOU WILL
SUPERVISE DISSEMINATE THE
INFORMATION ABOUT THE
REQUIREMENTS THAT THEY EXPECT
EMPLOYERS AND IN PARTICULAR
SMALL EMPLOYERS TO COMPLY WITH.
BECAUSE I THINK THERE'S ROOM FOR
IMPROVEMENT THERE AND I'M
CONFIDENT THAT YOU CAN.
DO IT THANK YOU THANK YOU MAYOR
PRO TEM SOMETHING I'M VERY MUCH
LOOKING FOR TO WORKING ON BOTH --
AT THE STATEWIDE LEVEL BUT ALSO
AS OF THIS OUT WE SHOULD BE
REGIONAL AND TARGETED AND
WORKING WITH MAYBE A LOCAL
CHAMBERS WHO KNOW BEST WITH A
SMALL BUSINESSES ARE. TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE ARE REACHING THEM
AND AND PROVIDING THE PROPER
INFORMATION AND WE DO HAVE SOME
EXPERIENCE FROM DOING THAT IN A
PRIOR CAMPAIGN IN.
TWO THOUSAND FOURTEEN ALWAYS
THAT IS A CRIME AND I DO HAVE
IDEAS ABOUT --
POSSIBLY USING MONEY THAT HAS
BEEN CUT IN THE PA THE FUNDS
WHICH ARE SUPPOSED TO BE FOR OUR
REGION EDUCATION TO DO EXACTLY
WHAT YOU'RE SUGGESTING
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
OKAY LET ME ASK PEOPLE WHO ARE
HERE IN SUPPORT TO STEP FORWARD
GIVE YOUR NAME WHO YOU REPRESENT.
AND HOPEFULLY AGAIN GIVEN THE
LARGE VOLUME OF PEOPLE WHO ARE
STANDING UP --
A SENTENCE OR TWO THANK YOU
[inaudible]
SIT ON AND MEMBERS MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS CAITLYN VEGA FOR THE
CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION I AM.
SO HONORED TO BE HERE TO SUPPORT
THE CONFIRMATION OF JULIE STILL
WE ARE SO FORTUNATE AS
CALIFORNIANS THAT SOMEONE OF HIS
CALIBRE HAS DEDICATED HERSELF TO
PUBLIC SERVICE AND IN PARTICULAR.
A SOMEONE REPRESENTING WORKERS
I'M SO GRATEFUL THAT SHE HAS
DEDICATED A SO MUCH OF HER TIME
TO REBUILDING THE LABOR
COMMISSIONER'S OFFICE AND NOW
THE LABOR AGENCY.
I'M JULIE SU WITH SOMEONE WHO IS
RENOWNED AS A BRILLIANT LEGALMIND WELL RESPECTED BY ALL AS
YOU WILL SEE.
I I THINK BYE BYE ALL I'M IN GET
IS ONE OF THE MOST HUMBLE AND
KIND PEOPLE YOU WILL EVER MEET
I'M NOT ONLY WAS SHE INVOLVED IN.
HELPING.
TO REPRESENT A GROUP OF THAI
GARMENT WORKERS WHO WERE
ENSLAVED AND THEN WHEN THEY CAME
FORWARD AND REPORTED THAT THEY
WERE PUT INTO DEPORTATION
PROCEEDINGS.
NOT ONLY DID SHE REPRESENT THEM
AND HELP THEM WIN FREEDOM SHE
REMAINS FRIENDS WITH THEM TO
THIS DAY BECAUSE THAT'S THE KIND
OF PERSON SHE IS SHE BECAME.
PERSONALLY INVOLVED IN
ADVOCATING FOR THESE WORKERS AND
MAKING SURE THAT THEY HAD A
PIECE OF THIS AMERICAN DREAM AND
SO JUST EIGHT IT'S A BEAUTIFUL
THING TO SEE HER HAIR WITH HER
FAMILY TODAY WE ARE VERY
FORTUNATE.
THAT SHE IS BRINGING ALL OF HER
SKILLS AND EXPERIENCE THE WIDE
RESPECT SHE HAS --
ALL AROUND THE STATE TO THIS
POSITION THANK YOU VERY MUCH
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS THE
COMMISSION GUSMAN ON BEHALF OF
THE TEAMSTERS THE AMALGAMATED
TRANSIT UNION MACHINISTS I HAVE
P. T. LOCALS TWENTY AND TWENTY
ONE AND THE INLAND BOATMAN'S
UNION OF AMERICA AS WELL AS THE
CONSUMER ATTORNEYS OF CALIFORNIA
ALL IN STRONG SUPPORT OF OF
JULIE SU AND THE CONFIRMATION.
HERE --
WE'VE WORKED WITH ISSUE AND ASK
HER IN A POSITION OF THE LABOR
COMMISSIONER --
HELPING TEAMSTER DRIVERS IN THE
PORTS IN MANY MANY WORKERS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE OUR
COMMITMENT TO WORKERS --
IS -- WE
BELIEVE UNPARALLELED AND WE
SUPPORT HER.
CONFIRMATION I WOULD LIKE TO ADD
ONE THING ALBERTO TRICKLE
COULDN'T BE HERE ALREADY ASKED
ME TO LEND HIS SUPPORT ON BEHALF
OF THE APPLICANT ATTORNEYS.
THANK YOU.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE PRIDE ALSO KNOWN HAVE
THE AMERICAN FEDERATION OF STATE
COUNTY MUNICIPAL EMPLOYEES AS
WELL AS THE UNITED DOMESTIC
WORKERS --
HERE IN SUPPORT OF TWO ISSUES
CONFIRMATION TODAY OFFER THIS
VERY IMPORTANT --
POSITION --
YOU'VE HEARD --
MISS FIGURE FROM THE CAITLYN OF
FROM THE CALIFORNIA LABOR
FEDERATION AND SPEAK A BIT ABOUT --
THE WORK THAT SHE HAS BEEN DOING
ON BEHALF OF IMMIGRANT WORKERS
ACROSS THE STATE --
BUT YOU KNOW IT IS A REMARKABLE
I BELIEVED TO HAVE SOMEONE WITH
ADVOCATES MIND AND HEART WHO
WANTS TO STEP INTO SUCH AN
IMPORTANT ROLE IN TO ENSURE THAT.
BOTH THE WORKERS BUT ALSO --
SOME RECOURSE IN THE THE TOOLS
TO HELP --
FURTHER OUR ECONOMY HERE IN THE
STATES SO --
ELATED TO BE REPRESENT ASK ME --
AND SUPPORTED HER CONFIRMATION
TODAY.
THANK YOU.
MA'AM CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE CHRISTY VELMA BEHALF
OF CALIFORNIA PROFESSIONAL
FIREFIGHTERS.
I ALSO SEE MYSELF WITH MS VEGAS
REMARKS THEIR TRUE AND WE ARE
HONORED TO BE HERE TO SUPPORT
YOUR CONFIRMATION.
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON THE LEGACY OF
BROWER WITH THE MAINTENANCE
COOPERATION TRUST FUND WERE
STATEWIDE JANITORIAL
ORGANIZATION.
AND I'VE BEEN DEALING WITH THIS
AGENCY FOR ABOUT TWENTY YEARS I
HAVE WORKED DIRECTLY WITH FIVE
PREVIOUS LABOR COMMISSIONER'S.
PREVIOUS TO COMMISSIONER SUE AND
I COULD TELL YOU THAT THAT SHE
INHERITED DISASTROUS OPERATION
IT WAS AN AGENCY THAT MANY
CONSIDERED A WASTELAND.
AND WHAT SHE HAS BEEN ABLE TO DO
IN A HURRY YEARS HAS BEEN SO
IMPRESSIVE WHAT'S BEEN MOST
IMPRESSIVE ISN'T THE IMPACT ON
WORKERS BUT THAT SHE'S A BRIDGE
BUILDER.
AND I REPRESENT SEVENTY
RESPONSIBLE JANITORIAL COMPANIES
AND SHE MET WITH THEM FOR HOURS
EVERY YEAR AND SHE DEVELOPED
IDEAS ABOUT HOW TO UNDERSTAND
BILLS MARKET PRESSURES AND REACH
A BALANCE.
SO THAT EVERY ENFORCEMENT ACTION
IS ACTUALLY STRENGTHENING THE
WORKPLACE THE ECONOMY FOR
RESPONSIBLE RESPONSIBLE
EMPLOYERS AS WELL SO WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT.
MADAM SECRETARY THANK YOU THANK
YOU.
HAS A VERY WELL AT THE F. C. W.
WESTERN STATES COUNSEL ON BEHALF
OF A HUNDRED SEVENTY THOUSAND
MEMBERS WERE EXCITED TO SUPPORT
YOUR NOMINATION AS SECRETARY.
I THANK YOU FOR YOUR WORK AS
LABOR COMMISSION WE I LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUE TO WORK
TOGETHER THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
HELLO I'M CATHERINE PORTER WITH
THE CALIFORNIA HELPING ELSE LONG
COLLABORATIVE WERE A COALITION
THAT WORKS ON IMPROVING THE
HEALTH AND SAFETY AND WORKERS
RIGHTS.
OF THE LOW WAGE WORKER COMMUNITY
AND NAIL SALONS WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT SUPPORT JULIE SU TO THIS
POSITION.
THANK YOU.
VENTURE MEMBERS PAT MORAN WITH
THEIR AND READING ASSOCIATES
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF PROFESSIONAL
SCIENTISTS IN THE PROFESSIONAL
ENGINEERS IN CALIFORNIA
GOVERNMENT.
WE LIKE TO ASSOCIATE YOURSELF
WITH THE PREVIOUS COMMENTS IN
SUPPORT THE NOMINATION AND
CONFIRMATION OF SECRETARY SUIT
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS DYING
GILBERT ON BEHALF OF THE WALT
DISNEY COMPANY.
HOW WE TO USE VARIANCE
DISASTROUSLY SUPPORT?
SECRETARIES APPOINTMENT
CONFIRMATION A GREAT SUCCESS.
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS DANIELLE URBAN I'M
HERE ON BEHALF OF MEMBER
ORGANIZATIONS OF THE COALITION
OF LOW WAGE AN IMMIGRANT WORKER
ADVOCATE.
THE FOLLOWING GROUPS.
ASIAN AIR ASIAN AMERICANS
ADVANCING JUSTICE ASIAN MARKAKIS
ASIAN AMERICANS ADVANCING
JUSTICE LOS ANGELES.
BUT THAT IT LEGAL SERVICES
CALIFORNIA IMMIGRANT POLICY
CENTER CENTER FOR WORKERS RIGHTS
UNDER THE THAT CENTER LIKE ALL
THE LARA.
CENTER FOR WORKERS RIGHT.
CENTROLEGAL THE LARA.
CHINESE PROGRESSIVE ASSOCIATION
SAN FRANCISCO.
DELORES STREET COMMUNITY
SERVICES.
EMPLOYEE RIGHTS CENTER.
EQUAL RIGHTS ADVOCATE
[inaudible]
HE WON LEGAL AID AT WORK.
NATIONAL EMPLOYMENT LAW PROJECT.
NATIONAL IMMIGRATION LAW CENTER.
UCLA LABOR CENTER WOMEN'S
EMPLOYMENT RIGHTS CLINIC OF
GOLDEN GATE UNIVERSITY.
AND WORK SAFE.
WE ARE COALITION OF LOW WEIGHT
AN IMMIGRANT WORKER ADVOCATES.
THAT ARE BOTH LEGAL SERVICES AND
WORKERS CENTER TO WORK CLOSELY
WHEN A MAN SECRETARY WITH AT
LABOR COMMISSIONER HE'S BEEN THE
HEART OF FIGHTING WAGE THEFT IN
CALIFORNIA.
NOT JUST AS PART OF THE ARMY BUT
AS CAPTAIN AND HAS ENSURED THAT
THE WAGE CLAIM HEARING PROCESSES
ARE MORE FAIR AND EFFICIENT FOR
ALL PARTIES.
HER TRANSPARENCY IN MAKING RULES
AND DECISIONS MEANS FAIRNESS FOR
BOTH SIDES AND SHE IS APPLY
THESE RULES CONSISTENTLY ALONG
FOR PREDICTABILITY FOR BOTH
WORKERS AND EMPLOYERS.
WE ARE I'M HAPPY THAT SHE'S
STILL ACCOUNTABLE TO THE PEOPLE
OF CALIFORNIA AND ENFORCING THE
BASIC MINIMUM LABOR PROTECTIONS
THAT THE STATE HAS AFFORDED OUR
LOW WAGE WORKER COMMUNITY.
AND WE KNOW SHE WILL CONTINUE TO
DO SO IN HER NEW POSITION.
THANK YOU.
MADAM CHAIR CHRISTMANN KAYLEE IT
WITH A PREY AND MY KILLIAN OVER
THE LAST EIGHT YEARS QUITE A
NUMBER OF CLIENTS I'VE WORKED
WITH -- AND
AND THE INCOMING SECRETARY --
AS LONG TIME ADVOCATES FOR THE
WITH THE BUSINESS COMMUNITY
ESPECIALLY IN THE LABOR AND
EMPLOYMENT ARENA HAVE HAD A
WONDERFUL OPPORTUNITY TO WORK
WITH MISS YOU ON A LOT OF ISSUES
WI.
WE TALKED ABOUT ISSUES LIKE
PROPER WERE YEARS BEFORE DYNAMAX
TOOK PLACE --
PAGA WAGE THEFT AND OTHER THINGS
YOU KNOW ISN'T AS AN ADVOCATE OR
WHETHER YOU'RE IN WITH AN
INTEREST GROUP FOR THE GENERAL
PUBLIC I THINK THE MOST THAT YOU
CAN.
I ASK FOR IN YOUR ELECTED AND
APPOINTED OFFICIALS AS AN OPEN
MIND -- YOU
KNOW GIVING DUE CONSIDERATION --
TAKING THE TIME TO HEAR BOTH
SIDES AND THAT IS SOMETHING THAT
WE HAVE ALWAYS FOUND PERHAPS THE
BUSINESS COMMUNITY HAS AND
ALWAYS AGREED.
WITH MISS --
TO IN SOME OF HER DECISIONS AS
LABOR COMMISSIONER.
BUT WE'VE ALWAYS HAD THE UTMOST
RESPECT FOR HER WORK AND TOO
QUICK EXAMPLES OVER THE LAST
EIGHT YEARS THE LEGISLATURE.
ASSESSED INCREASED EMPLOYER
ASSESSMENTS TO HELP FUND THE LSE
IN THE LABOR COMMISSIONER'S
OFFICE.
AND A LOT OF LEGISLATORS.
SAID ARE YOU SURE YOU WANT TO DO
IT.
ABSOLUTELY JULIE SUES THE LABOR
COMMISSIONER SHE DOES A GREAT
JOB FAIR MINDED WHAT HAPPENS
WHEN SHE LEAVES.
WELL LET'S DEAL WITH THAT SHE'S
A GREAT LABOR COMMISSIONER A FEW
YEARS AGO WHEN THE FORMER PRO
TEM MR DE LEóN CARRIED A MAJOR
WAGE THEFT A BILL TO COMBAT THAT
WE WORKED WITH --
WITH OUR COLLEAGUES IN THE LABOR
COMMUNITY OF ONE OF THE
HALLMARKS OF THAT BILL WAS
SUBSTANTIALLY NEW SAID --
STATUTORY AUTHORITY FOR THE
LABOR AFTER THE PROVERBIAL BAD
ACTOR AND AGAIN QUESTIONS WERE
OFTEN RAISED.
WASN'T THAT TOO MUCH POWER FOR
THE LABOR COMMISSIONER YEAH BUT
JULIE SU WILL USE IT VERY FAIRLY
AND SO --
HOPEFULLY --
WHOEVER TAKES OVER AS THE LAOR
COMMISSIONER WILL CONTINUE TO DO
THE GOOD WORK THAT YOU'VE DONE
AND I KNOW THAT IS LABOR
SECRETARY YOU'LL DO A FANTASTIC
JOB.
SO WITH THAT I URGE YOUR
CONFIRMATION THANK YOU
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
TAYLOR JACKSON WITH THE
CALIFORNIA NURSES ASSOCIATION
HERE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THE
APPOINTMENT OF JULIE SU --
FOR THIS POSITION YOU REALLY
WANT TO SEE SOMEONE THAT IS A
STRONG ADVOCATE FOR WORKERS AND
WE COULDN'T HOPE FOR SOMEONE
BETTER THAN THE APPOINTEE
SITTING IN FRONT OF YOU --
AND WE REALLY LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH YOU CONGRATULATIONS
THANK YOU.
NICOLAS CHAVEZ ON BEHALF UNITED
FARM WORKERS UNITED FARMERS AN
ENTHUSIASTIC SUPPORT OF YOUR
CONFIRMATION AS SECRETARY OF
LABOR.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
I LARA CURTIS ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
WE ARE PLEASED TO SUPPORT THE
CONFIRMATION OF MISS SUE AND WE
REALLY APPRECIATE HER FAIR AND
BALANCED APPROACH AND AGAIN HER
VERY TARGETED ENFORCEMENT THANKS
SO MUCH.
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRED MEMBERS
LAURIE CHAMAR SMALL BUSINESS
CALIFORNIA ALSO THE NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF WOMEN BUSINESS
OWNERS CALIFORNIA CHAPTER.
I HAVE ALSO BROUGHT WITH ME THE
RISK INSURANCE MANAGEMENT
SOCIETY OF CALIFORNIA WHO WILL
BE SINGING JULIE SUSE.
RAISES AND WE ARE SO PROUD OF
YOU AND THANKFUL TO BE WORKING
WITH YOU AND CONGRATULATIONS TO
YOUR FAMILY YOU'VE RACED QUITE A
DAUGHTER [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
MADAM CHAIRMAN CLAY JACKSON ON
BEHALF OF AFFINITY GROUP
ADMINISTRATORS AS ITS PRESIDENT
AND AS A DIRECTOR OF THE
CALIFORNIA ALLIANCE OF SELF
INSURED GROUPS.
OTHERWISE KNOWN AS KASSIG WHICH
HAD WHICH HAS.
AND REPRESENTS TWO THOUSAND
EMPLOYERS OVER TO THREE HUNDRED
THOUSAND EMPLOYEES.
WE SUPPORT.
US SECRETARY SUSAN.
APPOINTMENT AND WE ASK THAT YOU.
DO SO TOO THANK YOU MUCH THANK
YOU.
THE AFTERNOON I'M DIANA RICH
FROM THE CHAIRMAN OR THE
CHAIRPERSON SORRY.
OF THE CALIFORNIA LEGISLATIVE
DELEGATION OF THE RISK AND
INSURANCE MANAGEMENT SOCIETY
WE'RE ASSOCIATION OF RISK
MANAGERS RISK MANAGER'S JOB IS
TO PROTECT THE ASSETS OF THEIR
ORGANIZATIONS.
AND WE THINK ARM PLAYS OUR MOST
IMPORTANT ASSET.
SO WE'VE BEEN VERY PLEASED WITH
THE WORKERS COMPENSATION REFORMS
OF RECENT YEARS THEY'VE ALLOWED
US TO GET THROUGH A LOT OF RED
TAPE BE ABLE TO DELIVER BETTER
BENEFITS TO EMPLOYEES DIRECTLY.
WE SUPPORT THE CONTINUATION OF
THAT SO AND WE WOULD LIKE TO
SUPPORT THE NOMINATION OF
MISSING YOU THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
RENE BAYARDO IS HERE YOU
CALIFORNIA IT WAS GREAT TO HEAR
YOU TALK ABOUT YOUR FAMILY.
I THINK THAT THAT EXPERIENCE
REALLY SHOWS THAT YOU UNDERSTAND
HOWOF BAD ACTORS IN THE SYSTEM
REALLY DO HURT EMPLOYERS AND
WORKERS ALIKE --
WE'VE HAD A GREAT WORKING
RELATIONSHIP AND LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH YOU MORE.
THANK YOU.
MADAM CHAIR MADAM CHAIRWOMAN AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY NAME
IS CHARLES AYE TROLLS WHO
REPRESENTATIVE OF THE CALIFORNIA.
DELEGATION AND LEGISLATIVE
DELEGATION OF THE RISK
MANAGEMENT INSURANCE SOCIETY.
WE'RE HERE TO REALLY SUPPORT
WHOLEHEARTEDLY SUPPORT MISUSED
NOMINATION AND ALSO GLAD TO SEE
YOU HERE AND LOOKING FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH YOU IN THE FUTURE
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
JOHN CABOT TECH ON THE
CALIFORNIA STATE DIRECTOR WITH
THE NFIB NATIONAL FEDERATION OF
INDEPENDENT BUSINESS WE
REPRESENT ABOUT.
TWENTY THOUSAND SMALL AND
INDEPENDENT BUSINESSES AROUND
THE STATE WE'RE VERY PLEASED TO
SUPPORT YOUR NOMINATION TODAY
AND LOOKING FORWARD TO WORKING
WITH YOU WE KNOW YOU HAVE A
GREAT UNDERSTANDING --
AND AND HAVE A HISTORY OF HIGH
LEVEL OF INTEGRITY IN THE
WORKPLACE BETWEEN THE WORKER AND
THE EMPLOYER MAKING SURE THAT
THERE'S A WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
PROCESS THAT'S EFFECTIVE AND
SUCCESSFUL.
AND MOST UPON THE MAKING SURE
THAT SMALL BUSINESSES WHICH WE
ARE THE LARGEST JOB GENERATOR IN
ENDICOTT ECONOMIC DRIVER IN
CALIFORNIA OUR SUCCESSFUL YOU'VE
GOT THAT HISTORY WAS LOOKING
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH YOU AND
THE ADMINISTRATION MOVING
FORWARD.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
REVENUE MADAM CHAIR MARKER
PRAYER WITH A PRIME A KAYLEE ON
BEHALF THE CALIFORNIA WORKFORCE
IS.
ASSOCIATION A CW AYE SUPPORTS --
THE CONFIRMATION OF SECRETARIES
TO A SHE HAS DEMONSTRATED A
STRONG RECORD OF FIGHTING FOR
WORKERS AND FAMILIES.
AND SHE UNDERSTANDS THE
IMPORTANCE OF DIRECTING SERVICES
AND OPPORTUNITIES TO THE HARDEST
TO SERVE COMMUNITIES WE
ENCOURAGE SECRETARIES TO EXPLORE
OPPORTUNITIES. TO INVEST IN THE
WORK OF THE MEMBERS AND THE
CHAIR THE CALIFORNIA WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT BOARD.
AND WE WELCOME THE OPPORTUNITY
OF WORKING THANK YOU THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON A TEMPERAMENT
INTERNATION OF OPERATING
ENGINEERS IT'S AN HONOR TO A
ENDORSEMENTS --
TO YOUR CAPACITIES LABOR
COMMISSION WHO HAD EXPERIENCE
WITH HER WORKING WITH --
DIFFICULT ISSUES WITH BOTH LABOR
AND MANAGEMENT --
DEALT WITH BIG ISSUES AND BIG
PERSONALITIES AND SHE HANDLED
VERY WELL AND IN A VERY DIRECT
WAY UP BUT ALSO I THINK SHE'S A
PROPER ONE WORD INDUSTRY THIS
CAN BE IMPACTED BY NEW
TECHNOLOGIES IN A DRAMATIC WAY.
HERE IN THE NEAR FUTURE I THINK
SHE'S CERTAINLY THE RIGHT ONE TO
THE RIGHT PERSON TO HANDLE THE
JOB THANK YOU VERY MUCH
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE JEREMY SMITH YOU
ON BEHALF OF THE STATE BUILDING
AND CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL
AS WELL AS THE DISTRICT COUNCIL
OF OUR WORKERS --
YOU'VE PROVEN TO BE INEFFECTIVE.
A DEDICATED AND KIND PUBLIC
SERVANT AND WE LOOK FOR LOWER
KING WITH YOU FOR THE NEXT
SEVERAL YEARS THANK YOU
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
VENTURE MEMBERS WAS IN HERE THE
LABOR STATE COUNCIL PROBABLY IN
SUPPORT OF THE SECRETARY.
HE'S COMMITTEE COMMITTED SHE IS
A PUBLIC SERVANT THAT HAS NO IN --
TO HER DAY'S WORK AND WE CAN BE
MORE PROVINCETOWN HERE VIRGINIA
CONFIRMATION REGULARS.
THANK YOU.
I'M SURE MEMBERS MIKE MONACAN
BEHALF THE CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF ELECTRICAL
WORKERS THE CALIFORNIA STATE
PATRIOTS COUNCIL THE WESTERN
STATES COUNCIL OF SHEET METAL
WORKERS.
AND THE INTERNATIONAL UNION OF
ELEVATOR CONSTRUCTORS AND SINCE
I'M LAST IN LINE DO I HAVE LIKE
OPEN ENDED TIME.
NO BUT WE HAVE AN ELEVATOR ON
THIS SIDE OF THE BUILDING THAT
ACTUALLY NEEDS SOME SERIOUS WORK.
I'LL GET ON THAT THANK YOU.
LIKE TO ASSOCIATE MY REMARKS
WITH MY BROTHERS IN THE
CONSTRUCTION INDUSTRY AND LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH THE
SECRETARY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
LET ME ASK IF THERE'S ANYONE
HERE IN OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU ARE I WILL ACCEPT
MISTER ROSS OUR MOTION MADAM
SECRETARY WE PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
SENATORS BATES AYE BATES ONLINE
MONNING THANK MONNING AYE ROTH.
ROUGH I WILL.
WILK I I BROAD COALITION OF
PEOPLE YOU HAVE BROUGHT HERE
TODAY I YEAH I THINK WE WERE ALL
MINDFUL.
OF THE RANGE OF STAKEHOLDERS SO
WE CAN GRADUALLY YOU ON A
UNANIMOUS DECISION AN
APPOINTMENT
HI.
AS WE AS WE ARE EXITING WE ARE
GOING TO MOVE INTO EXECUTIVE
SESSION SO.
WE WILL WAIT UNTIL FOLKS EXIT
BUT WE HAVE CONCLUDED OUR
BUSINESS IN THE PUBLIC ARENA.
AND WE'LL MOVE INTO EXECUTIVE
SESSION